STARTED SUBCOMMITTEE -- WE HAVE
ONE ANNOUNCEMENT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA WILL BE
REPLACING FILLED HANG ON A
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY.
WITH THAT MISTER CELL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN.
MOST STARTING WITH FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN A. B.. SIX ORDER OF
BUSINESS TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
WHAT SB SIX EIGHTEEN DOES IS
AUTHORIZES CITIES CUTS VALLEY?
TO INCREASE THEIR SALES AND USE
TAX ABOVE THE STATUTORY LIMIT.
CITIES GOT SALLY IS -- LOW
WEALTH CITY AND HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FINANCES MEDIA HAS BEEN.
ACTUALLY WORKING VERY VERY
RESPONSIBLY AND IS IN THE
PROCESS OF INVESTIGATING THEIR
FINANCES.
SHOULD THEY DISCOVER THEY NEED
TO INCREASE THEIR SALES AND USE
TAX LIMIT THEIR ASKING THAT WE
INCREASE THE THEIR AUTHORITY TO
DO SO.
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY GOING OUT TO THEIR
VOTERS TO SEEK THAT TAX INCREASE
IT WOULD STILL BE.
A SUPER MAJORITY OF VOTERS IN
ORDER TO APPROVE THAT TAX
INCREASE AND REYES I HAVE THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY IT'S GOT SALLY
WITH ME WHO IS MAKING THE
REQUEST AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER -- ADD A FEW WORDS
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR BURKE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
DOCTOR WAS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
SCOTTS VALLEY.
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
WERE ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE SB -- SIX EIGHTEEN AB
SIX EIGHTEEN THIRTY WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE CITY TO IMPLEMENT UPON
VOTER APPROVAL.
WE NEED TO VOTER APPROVAL OF THE
TRANSACTION USE TAX THAT WOULD
EXCEED THE CAP WOULD NORMALLY BE
IN PLACE UNDER STATE LAW.
DISCUSS THOUGH IT DOES HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF OF IMPLEMENTING
AND PROVIDING LEAN COST.
OUR SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC.
AND WE WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON
THAT WE HAVE HAD TO REDUCE OUR
STAFFING OVER THE YEARS AND
882-608-6260.
SIX AND WE HAVE GONE OUT TO THE
VOTERS TWICE WHEN WE REALLY
NEEDED TO FOR TEMPORARY --
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX
APPROVALS BEFORE AND THOSE WERE
APPROVED -- BY 71275% MARGIN SO
WE HAVE STRONG VOTER SUPPORT
EVEN THOUGH -- I THINK IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE WATCH A
DOLLAR SO CLOSELY.
WE DID -- WE DO HAVE SOLID
FINANCIAL RESERVES A WE ADOPTED
A A TEN YEAR.
SCHOOL STATE ABILITY PLAN LAST
YEAR UP TO DEAL WITH ITS HAZARDS
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
STRONG A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THEY
WILL USE UP OUR OUR OUR RESERVES
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING SOON IN
TERMS OF OF STEPS AND THIS -- AB
SIX EIGHTEEN WILL HELP US SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM AS AS ONE OPTION AS
A THE SUMMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE REVIEW BY STANDARD AND
POOR'S -- AND THEY REAFFIRMED
ARE VERY STRONG DOUBLE A MINUS
BOND RATING -- AND THEY AND AND
THAT WAS PARTLY DUE TO OUR OUR
RESERVES ARE SOME RESERVES ARE
STRONG MANAGEMENT.
AND OR FISCAL YEAR OR FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY POINT SO THE
STANDARD POOR'S RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE TAKING THE STEPS WE NEED
TO TAKE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
ADDITIONAL STEP IF WE NEED TO
SOAR ASKING THE THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE AB.
SIX ONE EIGHT THE WOULD ALLOW US
TO GIVE THE VOTERS THE OPTION TO
PROVE THIS TAX AT SO THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT THE COMMUNITY EXPECTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND THANK YOU TO SO MANY OF OUR
STONE FOR A BRING FORTH THIS
BILL.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YES
MA'AM FOR MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO
YOU -- A. B. SIX ONE EIGHT HERE
TODAY.
AND MEMBERS JUST BE COR AGAIN
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE
AS BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE
WITNESS ALLUDED.
TO IS AN AUTHORIZATION OF
ATTACKS THIS DOES STORE CHOIR
VOTER APPROVAL FROM THE CITIZENS
OF SCOTT VALLEY SCOTTS VALLEY
AND OF COURSE WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT.
BUT YET MEMBERS WE DO OPPOSE
THIS TAX AUTHORIZATION BILL AS
WE'VE OPPOSE ALL SORTS OF OTHER
TAX AUTHORIZATION BELLS
CERTAINLY IN THE TWELVE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN AT HOWARD JARVIS --
FOR THE SIMPLE REASON SALES TAX
INCREASES EVEN THE QUARTER CENT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
ARE INCREDIBLY REGRESSIVE.
AND YOU KNOW ADDS TO THE BURDEN
THAT INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS PAY
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY HAS THE
HIGHEST SALES TAX IN THE NATION
BY FAR IN THE CITY OF SCOTTS
VALLEY ALREADY HAS A SALES TAX
INCREASE.
RATE OF 9% AND TO PUT THAT
FIGURE IN PERSPECTIVE THAT TAX
RATE IS ALREADY IN THE TOP 20%.
OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
LOCAL CALIFORNIA JURISDICTIONS
THAT LEVY SALES TAXES SO SCOTTS
VALLEY ALREADY HAS.
A SALES TAX THAT CERTAINLY
HIGHER THAN THE STATE AVERAGE IN
A THINK ADDING TO THAT -- EVEN
THOUGH THE REASONS MAY WELL BE
THE ALLIED IS INAPPROPRIATE I
WOULD ALSO SAY TO MEMBERS JUST
IN CLOSING THE BRADLEY BURNS
SALES TAX ACT HAS BEEN AROUND
SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY SIX AND
WHAT THAT DID WAS SET A UNIFORM
SALES TAX RATE.
OF 2% ACROSS ALL MUNICIPALITIES
WE DO THINK THIS IS A FAIR SALES
TAX RATE IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES -- IT'S INAPPROPRIATE TO
EXCEED THE RATE I MEAN AGAIN
IT'S BEEN AROUND FIFTY YEARS WHY
DO WE NEED TO EXCEED THEIR EIGHT
YET WE SEE ALSO ITS
MUNICIPALITIES DOING THIS.
AND IN FACT THE REASON WHY THIS
BILL NEEDS TO COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY IS BECAUSE
WE'RE EXCEEDING THAT BRADLEY
BURNS 2% RATE -- DON'T THINK
IT'S NECESSARY SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WOULD ASK FOR AN OF A
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
START WORK.
YEAH I THINK LOCAL FOLKS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHAT THEIR
TAX RATES GOING TO BE AND I'D BE
IN FAVOR OF JUST ALLOWING IT NO
CITIES THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SAYING NINE A SUMMER STONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
TALK ABOUT REGRESSIVE TAXES WENT.
REALLY WE'VE LEFT VERY FEW
LEVERS FOR CITIES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THEIR REVENUE NEEDS.
A VERY EFFECTIVE CITY LIKE
SCOTTS VALLEY VERY FISCALLY
PRUDENT CITY LIKES LIKES CUTS
BELLY IS REALLY RUNNING OUT OF
OPTIONS BECAUSE OF THE
INEQUITIES OF THE PROPERTY TAX
SYSTEM.
AND THE THE LACK OF BALANCE
THERE IN FACT THE 9% RATE IF WE
ACTUALLY APPLIED SALES AND USE
TAX.
EQUITABLY ACROSS THE ECONOMY WE
WOULD BE TAXING SERVICES A COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY DROPPED THE RIGHT
SO TO BE FOCUSING ON A 9% RATE
WHEN WHAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON IS THE BASE OF A WHICH THAT
IS APPLIED.
AND THE INEQUITIES IN THE
PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM.
WE OTHERWISE LEAVE.
CITIES WITH NO OTHER CHOICES BUT
TO COME TO US.
AND AMEND A BILL THAT IS SIXTY
YEARS OLD AND IN THE MEANTIME
THE MUCH TAX POLICY HAS IN FACT
CHANGED SO NOT ONLY IS THIS JUST
THE BY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE ALLOWED.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR CITIES WAR
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN A MORE
HONEST WAY IS IS TAX REFORM AND
LOOK AT HOW REVENUES ARE
COLLECTED AND REVENUES ARE
ADJUSTED IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
REALLY NO OTHER CHOICE BEFORE US.
BUT THE LET FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
CITIES DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO I
THEREFORE ASK FOR YOUR HIGH
ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND OUR RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WILL TAKE IT UP
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
CERVANTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COME UP.
AND THIS IS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY RANKS FIFTH LARGEST IN
THE WORLD THIS PROSPERITY HAS BY
PASSED SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ROUTINELY FACE
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT AS AN
INCENTIVE FOR EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS FROM CERTAIN
TARGETED POPULATIONS INCLUDING
AN UNEMPLOYED VETERANS.
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
DISABILITY AND THE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED THE CALIFORNIA
WATCHED SEEM BUILDS UPON THE
FEDERAL WATCH HE PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FOR THIRD PARTY
VERIFICATION OF EMPLOYEE A
LEGIBILITY.
ACCORDING TO THE WAR IN BUSINESS
SCHOOL STUDY CALIFORNIA SAVES
OVER A HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN CONTRIBUTIONS TOWARDS
TâM SNAPPED SNAPPED AND
MEDICAID EACH YEAR AS A RESULT
OF THE FEDERAL WATCHED SEE.
BY ADOPTING A STATE WHAT SEE
CALIFORNIA FURTHERS ITS GOAL I
THINK OF AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH BY SISSY INDIVIDUALS WITH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT MOVE FROM
WELFARE TO WORK WITH ME TO
TESTIFY OR NUMBER OF SUPPORTERS.
I WHICH ONE PRODUCE THEMSELVES
TODAY.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS COULD
SPECULATE ON BEHALF OF COUNTY
AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WE WORKED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION YEARS AGO ON THE
ELIMINATION OF THE EASY PROGRAM
IN THE CREATION OF AMONGST OTHER
PROVISIONS THE NEW EMPLOYMENT
CREDIT AND UNFORTUNATELY AS YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
EXPLAINS HAS BEEN VASTLY UNDER
UTILIZED INSTEAD OF PROVIDING.
SIXTY OR SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND BENEFIT TAX BENEFIT
IT'S LESS THAN A MILLION DOLLARS.
SO WE STARTED LOOKING AT WHAT
ARE ALTERNATIVES AND THE FEDERAL
WATCH C. WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE EVER SINCE AND IS
IT TARGETED AT INDIVIDUAL
SIMILAR TO THE ANY SEE WITHOUT
THOSE LIMITATIONS.
AND THE OTHER BENEFIT IS THAT IT
BUILDS OFF OF AND UTILIZES THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ET DE WHICH GOES
THROUGH THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS SO WE THINK THAT.
A STATE WHAT SEE IS A FAR BETTER
ALTERNATIVE TO TAKE AND I WOULD
ALSO NOTE MADAM CHAIR THAT THE
BILL COMPLIES WITH BOTH.
OF THE COMMITTEE REQUIREMENTS A
SUNSET DATE AS WELL AS THE
EVALUATION METRICS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT I MEAN A LOT TO
BENSON AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
NETWORK.
IT'S A NETWORK MADE UP OF A
PROFESSIONAL TAX PREPARERS CPA'S
AND PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR SITE
SELECTION FOR COMPANIES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO EITHER MOVE OR CHANGE
LOCATION -- WE COVET TO THOSE
WHO DO LOOK AT CALIFORNIA AS A
SITE BECAUSE THAT'S TYPICALLY
NOT WHAT HAPPENS.
SO THEY LOOK AT OBVIOUSLY THINGS
THAT WOULD BRING PEOPLE TO
CALIFORNIA AND CREATE AN ALL ON
OPPORTUNITY IN AN INCENTIVE FOR
BUSINESS.
THIS IS A BUSINESS INCENTIVE
CREATING THE WORK OPPORTUNITY
TAX CREDIT IN CALIFORNIA TO MOVE
WITH ALONG WITH THE FEDERAL
WORKING ALONG WITH THE FEDERAL
WHAT SEE -- BUT IT IS ABOUT
HELPING PEOPLE WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T TYPICALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY -- FIND THE
JOBS AND WE ARE.
LOOKING -- TO TO TO EXTEND WHAT
THE FEDERAL WHAT'S HE DOES THIS
ALSO CREATES CREATES A RETENTION
SO THAT THE EMPLOYEES STAYS WITH
THE EMPLOYER LONGER THERE'S THAT
THAT'S BUILT INTO THE CALIFORNIA
WANT SEE.
WE THINK FOR THOSE THINGS THE
EXISTING FEDERAL WATCH SEE AN
ADDING THAT CALIFORNIA ONCE HE
WOULD BE A BETTER HIRING CREDIT
THAN WE HAVE TODAY.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN ALSO ORDER A MAP OF THE
HUNDRED THOUGH ALSO [inaudible]
YEAH QUESTION.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE DOT
QUIRK -- SO WITHIN THE ANALYSIS
SECTION DE UNDER COMMENTS.
OF THIS QUESTION ABOUT
EFFECTIVENESS AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GIVE ME -- A LONG ANSWER
TODAY BUT BEFORE WE VOTE ON THIS --
IF YOU CAN -- PERHAPS SEND ME
AND OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
SOME INFORMATION ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
SURE.
MADAM CHAIRMAN I RESPOND BRIEFLY.
DOCTOR QUIRK -- JUST A COUPLE OF
ITEMS I KNOW THAT.
THE ANALYSIS CITED SOME EARLIER
STUDIES FROM -- TWO THOUSAND ONE
TWO I THINK THE AUTHOR HAS CITED
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN WHARTON
SCHOOL -- IT HAS BEEN STUDIED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL QUITE
EXTENSIVELY SINCE ITS ENACTMENT
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX BUT WILL
PROVIDE GREATER DETAIL TO YOU ON
THOSE ADDITIONAL STUDIES.
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
IT ALL TODAY BUT I'D LOVE TO SEE
IT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE SEVEN OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT WHEN IT'S
READY TO COME
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIX ELEVEN
TWENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
THIS IS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY AS YOU ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A BOOMING
CRAFT DISTILLER INDUSTRY IT'S
ESTIMATED THERE THAT THERE ARE
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CRAFTED STORIES IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY.
AND THIS NUMBER IS GROWING
RAPIDLY.
CURRENT TAX REGULATIONS ALLOW
FOR A SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
OAK BARRELS USED IN THE
PRODUCTION OF BRANDY OR WINE.
THIS EXEMPTION DOES NOT HOWEVER
APPLY TO OAK BARRELS USED FOR
DISTILLED SPIRITS.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY WOULD SIMPLY
ADD OAK BARRELS TO THE SALES
EXEMPTION ON A LIMITED FIVE YEAR
SUNSET BASIS.
WITH ME TO MY RIGHT IS MY FRIEND
ALEX BILL KANA HE'S A DISTILLER
MY DISTRICT IN THESE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR AT FIRST TAKE TAKING A LOOK
AT THIS BILL -- I'VE BEEN A
DISTILLER AND A WINE MAKER AND
THAT THE PASTOR WAS REGION FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
ORIGINALLY WHEN I STARTED MAKING
WINE BARRELS WERE TAXED AND THEY
WEREN'T LOOKED AT AS AN
INGREDIENT THEY WERE LOOKED AT
AS A STORAGE CONTAINER.
AND THE REALITY IS OAK BARRELS
ARE HORRIBLE STORAGE CONTAINERS
BECAUSE THEY LEAK BUGS EAT THEM
THEY GO BAD.
I STAINLESS STEEL IS A MUCH
BETTER OPTION.
AND SO IT WAS CLARIFIED A NUMBER
OF YEARS BACK THAT WINE WAS
ACTUALLY AN INGREDIENT EVERYBODY
TALKS ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S OKEY
CHARDONNAY IS WONDERFUL
CABERNET'S.
IT IS A FLAVOR PROFILE THAT ADDS.
THAT CHARACTERISTIC TO THE WIND
THAT CONSUMERS LIKE.
I'M.
WHEN THE BILL WAS ART WHEN THE
RULES WERE ESTABLISHED THERE WAS
NO DISTILLING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA SPEAK UP -- I HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO WE STARTED
OUR DISTILLERY IMPASSE ROBLES
THEY WERE ONLY ABOUT TWENTY
DISTILLERS IN THE STATE AT THE
TIME -- SO THE RULES REALLY
HADN'T LOOKED AT SPIRITS BARRELS --
ACTUALLY IN SPIRITS IT IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT TO PUT THEM IN
OAK BARRELS BECAUSE WHEN I
SPIRITS I COME OFF THE STILL
THERE ACTUALLY CLEAR AND DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF FLAVOR.
AND SO THE OAK BARREL WILL
ACTUALLY IN PART NOT ONLY THE
COLOR BUT A LOT OF THE FLAVORS
THAT MOST CONSUMERS I EXPECT
FROM THERE FOR THE FROM THEIR
AGE SPIRITS.
I'M SURE WE LOOK AT AN OAK
BARREL AS AN INGREDIENT I'M NOT
AS A STORAGE CONTAINER AND ALL
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS THAT THE
BARRELS FOR SPIRITS PRODUCTION
OUR LOOK AT THE SAME AS THEY ARE
FOR WINE.
AND AT THE END OF THE CYCLE WILL
BE TAXED ON THE PRODUCT THAT
COMES OUT OF THOSE BARRELS WILL
BE SOLD TO THE CONSUMER AND
TAXED.
SO THE SALES TAX IS GETTING A
PICKED UP BUT IT JUST AT A LATER.
DATE AND TIME -- I WOULD
APPRECIATE SUPPORT AT ON THIS
BILL JUST SO THAT SMALL
DISTILLERS LIKE MYSELF -- WHO
HAVE SMALL FAMILY BUSINESSES
HAVE CLARITY OF THE RULES SO WE
KNOW HOW TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE?
I'M I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS.
THANK YOU DISTILLNG THIS IS IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN MRS IN OPPOSITION?
THING NINE COMMENTS QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE DOCTOR BURKE.
TOM.
YES SO TO THE AUTHOR -- HAVE YOU
BEEN TALKING TO THE REGULATORY
AGENCY BECAUSE I'VE OFTEN FOUND
WORKING WITH THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES IF I CAN MAKE A GOOD
CASE THEY CAN.
CHANGE THE REGULATION -- HAVE
YOU BEEN ABLE TO DISCUSS THIS
WITH THEM.
I THINK WE'VE SPOKEN TO THEM BUT
THEY BELIEVE THERE IS A NEED FOR
STATUTORY CHANGE.
THIS COMMITTEE SEEMS THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF SEEMS TO BELIEVE
IT COULD BE DONE BY REGULATION --
WELL I'D BE VERY MUCH IN FAVOR
OF HELPING YOU ANYWAY I CAN
PERHAPS WE CAN GET THE G. O.
CHAIR -- TO WORK WITH THIS --
SINCE THAT -- COMMITTEE COMES
UNDER HIT THAT REGULATION WOULD
COME UNDER HIS COMMITTEE -- AND
I'D LOVE TO SEE THE REGULATION
CHANGED IT WOULD MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE AND THE PROBLEM YOU HAVE
WITH THIS IS ANYTIME YOU HAVE.
BILL THE COST MONEY YOU CAN GET
CAUGHT SEVERAL DIFFERENT WAYS
AND SO I'D BE GLAD TO HELP YOU
ANYWAY I CAN.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
THAT'S HIGH PRAISE COMING FROM
DOCTOR QUIRK ACTUALLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE SEEN NOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I WOULD LASTLY NOTE
THAT.
MISTER GORE CON IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF MOST CRAFTED
STORES IN CALIFORNIA ARE VERY
SMALL BUSINESSES SO -- IF YOU
CAN SEE YOUR SEE YOUR WAY TO
SUPPORTING THIS I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA HELP A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AROUND THE STATE
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB. TWELVE TWENTY WILL
PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT FOR
BUSINESS.
I THINK MADAM SPEAKER IF YOU'RE
HANDING IT OUT.
THERE START OUT AND CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS A. B. I
SEE I'M STILL ON AND FLOOR
SESSION THAT'S FROM I HAVE THAT
RIGHT NOW -- THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT FOR
BUSINESSES THAT PURCHASE
COMPOSABLE CUTLERY FOR CAN --
CUSTOMERS USE AT THEIR PLACE OF
BUSINESS THIS MEASURE ENCOURAGES
THE FOOD INDUSTRY TO MOVE AWAY
FROM SINGLE USE PLASTIC CUTLERY
INTO INSTEAD OPT FOR COMPOSABLE
OPTIONS I THINK ALL OF US ARE
WHERE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE -- HOW
DEVASTATING SINGLE USE PLASTIC
SUCH AS CUTLERY -- REALLY IS TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT SO WHAT THE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO JUST
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE TO BUSINESS
RATHER THAN BANNING THINGS LIKE
SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
THE PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE THAT
BUSINESSES COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF FOR SWITCHING FROM COMPULSIVE
TO A OF FROM A SINGLE USE
PLASTIC OPTION TO A COMBUSTIBLE
OPTION IT'S BETTER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND HELPS US --
REACH A ALREADY EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT REQUIRES 75%
RECYCLING COMPOSTING OR SOURCE
REDUCTION OF SOLID WASTE BY
TWENTY TWENTY SO WE CAN CONTINUE.
TO DECREASE OUR RELIANCE ON
LANDFILLS -- IT'S THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD
RESTORING PROTECTING OUR HEALTH --
IN OUR LOCAL ENVIRONMENT AND SO
IS BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THESE
REASONS THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS A GREAT FRIEND.
RECOLOGY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS STEPHANIE MORAL HERE ON
BEHALF OF APOLOGY FOR QUALITY IS
THAT 1100% EMPLOYEE OWNED
COMPANY THAT MANAGES RECYCLING
ORGANIC WASTES US AND SALAS
COLLECTION.
PROCESSING DISPOSAL SERVICES FOR
NEARLY A HUNDRED URBAN SUBURBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE AB TWELVE TWENTY
TAKES THE RIGHT APPROACH
INCURRING CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
SPREAD USE A PLASTIC
SPECIFICALLY PLASTIC UTENSILS
THAT HAVE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
ON OUR HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
BY INCENTIVIZING BUSINESSES TO
MAKE THE SWITCH TO REUSABLE OUR
COMPOSTABLE CUTLERY CALIFORNIA
CAN CONTINUE BEING A LEADER IN
SINGLE USE PLASTIC REDUCTION AND
WILL BE KEEPING IN LINE WITH THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENT OF 75%
RECYCLING.
COMPOSTING OUR SOURCE RUSSIAN BY.
TWENTY TWENTY RECOLOGY
RECOGNIZES THE IMPACTS OF SINGLE
USE PLASTICS AND IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON RESTORED
AT AND WASTE REDUCTION POLICIES
THAT UTILIZE SMART.
SIMPLE ALTERNATIVES LIKE
COMPOSABLE CUTLERY WHICH IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT AND A BEAUTIFUL TWENTY
ABOUT CHAIR -- AND JUST JUST AS
A POINT OF CLARIFICATION THAT
RIGHT NOW WE ARE OFFERING --
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL TO
ADD A FIVE YEAR SUNSET -- A AN
AMENDMENT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
COMPLYING WITH SECTION FORTY ONE
FROM TAX CODE -- WE'RE GOING TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TAX CREDIT
CREDIT FROM 100% WE'RE STILL
WORKINGON NUMBER RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LOOKING ABOUT 20%.
ON AND ALSO REMOVES THE RESERVE
REASONABLE CUTLERY FROM THE
LANGUAGE SO THE FOCUSES ONLY ON
COMPOSABLE AS WELL AS A COUPLE
LITTLE BIT OTHER DETAIL LANGUAGE
AND IN TERMS OF DEFINING FOOD
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IS IN OPPOSITION?
STING NINE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ON
INCLUDING WHAT.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED AS
HE'S CONSIDERING FOR A MOMENT.
SO.
PERHAPS YOUR TECHNICAL EXPERT
CAN DISCUSS THIS SO I'VE.
GONE ACROSS THE STATE TALKING
PEOPLE COMPOSED.
MOST OF THEM CAN'T COMPOSED THE
SO CALLED COMPOSED DOUBLE
PLASTIC AND WE'VE WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS BEFORE -- DAY
COMPULSIVE BOWL CUTLERY RATHER
AND REASON IS THAT THEY
BASICALLY THEY DO THIS IN LARGE
PILES AND PILES NEVER GET ALL
THAT HOT.
THE ONLY DO IT FOR A FEW MONTHS
AND BY THEN THE COUPLE REALLY
REALLY HASN'T COME COMPOSED AND
SO THAT THEY HAVE TO SIR TO
SCRAPE IT OUT.
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T GO IN WITH
COMPOSED BILL MATERIALS I GATHER
RECOLOGY APPARENTLY IS ABLE TO
COMPOSE THEM PERHAPS USE A
HIGHER HEAT PROCESS I'D.
JUST BE CURIOUS ABOUT THAT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING I I
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK CO AND I
WOULD HAVE TO OKAY -- SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE COMPOSED
THINGS THEY DO IT IN THIS PILE
METHOD AND THE TEMPERATURES JUST
ARE HARD ENOUGH TO DECOMPOSE THE
OUR CUTLERY SO I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK INTO
THAT TECHNICAL ISSUE AND I KNOW
RECOLOGY WOULD BE.
QUITE A GOOD SOURCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SEVEN MEMBER
AND WE'RE GONNA WORK CLOSELY
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE WE GET
RIGHT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THE SCENE
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SPEC LAST
WHEN I WROTE THANK YOU IT'S FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY WHEN WE TAKE A
VOTE [inaudible]
IT'S NOW.
AND EVEN IF I AM TWELVE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO TO LIKE.
TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
SEAT.
THANK YOU MA'AM TURN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY --
IN IN THIS TESTIMONY ONLY
HEARING I WOULD LIKE.
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
CREATE A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
TAX CREDIT FOR LOW OR MODERATE
INCOME FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
WHO PURCHASED A PRINCIPAL
RESIDENCE LOCATED.
IN A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
WITH THE WORSENING HOUSING
CRISIS OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST
TIME HOME OWNERSHIP IS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
LIMITED DUE TO INCREASING COSTS
ESPECIALLY FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES OF LOWELL AND MARK AND
OR MODERATE INCOME.
THESE INCREASING COSTS INCLUDE
UNFORESEEN EXPENSES THAT CAN
OCCUR SOON AFTER PURCHASE SUCH
AS AN ANTICIPATED REPAIRS.%
THESE UNFORESEEN EXPENSES CAN
ALSO THE FIRST TIME.
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOMEBUYERS EXASPERATED AS A
STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR HOME
OWNERSHIP.
WITH THE SKYROCKETING RENTAL AND
HOUSING COSTS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AB FIFTY NINETY CREATE THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES LOOKING TO PURSUE THE
PATHWAYS TO HOME OWNERSHIP.
THIS BILL PROMOTES FINANCIAL
PROSPERITY AMONG DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO INVEST IN THEIR FUTURE BY
BECOMING FIRST TIME HOMEWORK
BUYERS.
THE TAX CREDIT IN THIS BILL WILL
BE.
NARAL NARROWLY TAILORED TO HOME
BUYERS THAT DO NOT EXCEED A
HUNDRED AND 20% OF THEM AIMED MY
AND USES EXISTING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IDENTIFIED.
CENSUS TRACTS DOES DESIGNATED BY
CAL EPA.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE.
CAREENED GREASY ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSORS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF CREAM GREASY ON THE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS -- VERY PROUD TO BE
THE SPONSOR OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
IN HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTED SUCH TIME AS MADAM
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE DEEM
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EMILY I CAN HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
START COURT [inaudible]
I'M AWAKE -- SO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IS IDENTIFIED
PURSUANT TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE SECTION -- THREE NINE SEVEN
ONE ONE I'M JUST THINKING IS
THAT THE SO CALLED ENVIRONMENTAL
SCREEN OR IS THAT A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM BY THAT CAL EPA IF I'M
CORRECT.
YES.
THAT'S ENVIRONMENTAL SCREEN YES
SIR YES IT'S YET THE DIFFICULTY
WITH THAT IS THAT.
SOME OF OUR HERE'S A PLACE WHERE
THE BAY AREA IN OTHER COME
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
GOOD AIR BECAUSE THEY'RE STRONG
WIND OFF THE THEY ARE OFF THE
SEA.
REALLY DO NEED HELP ARE
ORDINARILY I DO SUPPORT USING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SCREEN BUT
SINCE THE ENVIRONMENTAL SCREEN
DEPENDS UPON YOUR HAVING POOR
AIR.
AND PLACES LIKE EAST PALO ALTO
WHICH ARE CLEARLY.
ON COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED BUT HAVE GOOD AIR
I THINK SHOULD BE INCLUDED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITH MANY.
THE SCENE THEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP INTO
HOMEOWNERSHIP WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE ARE TENDING TO
FOCUS MAINLY ON APARTMENTS.
BUT WE KNOW THAT BUILDING WEALTH
IS PRIMARILY -- STARTED WITH
HOME OWNERSHIP AND SO MY GOAL IS
TO HELP WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
BUT ALSO TO GIVE THE
DISADVANTAGE -- COMMUNITIES --
NOT PERTINENT TO THRIVE BUT ALSO
THE LOW TO MODERATE INCOME FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO START BUILDING
WHAT HER THEIR FAMILIES IN THE
FUTURE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A MOVING TO FILE ITEM. TEN AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO YEAR OTHER
BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT -- YET
ANOTHER BILL -- TESTIMONY ONLY
OUR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS A
CRITICAL PROBLEM FACING
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA'S LIKELY TO FACE A
SHORTAGE OF WORKERS.
THEY MAY BE AS HIGH AS ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THOSE JOBS THAT
REQUIRE SOME COLLEGE EDUCATION.
IN MY DISTRICT I REPRESENT THE
CITY OF IRWINDALE AND THE CITY
OF INDUSTRY TO AREAS THAT ARE
MANUFACTURING HUBS IN CALIFORNIA.
EVERY TIME I GO HOME WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS A CONSTANT THEME.
EMPLOYERS IN CERTAIN THE
INDUSTRIES ARE LOOKING TO HIRE
AND TO GROW NOW BUT HAVE NO
WORKER POOL TO FILL NEEDED
POSITIONS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
ATTEMPTS TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM
BY CREATING A TAX CREDIT FOR
EMPLOYERS TO CREATE A WORKING
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
THE AMOUNT OF THE TAX CREDIT IS
CAPPED AT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PARK PER EMPLOYEE PER TAXABLE
YEAR AND TAILORED TO SPECIFIC
INDUSTRIES IN THE MOST NEEDED.
I MOST NEED OF WORKFORCE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN HUMAN
CAPITAL AND ITS IMPACT ON
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
HAS BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED
INVESTMENT IN HUMAN CAPITAL
IMPROVE WORKERS PRODUCTIVITY
SPUR INNOVATION AND PROVIDE
PATHWAYS FOR CAREER UPWARD
MOBILITY.
AS INNOVATION IN AUTOMATION
DISRUPT THE ECONOMY WORKERS WILL
NEED TRAINING TO WORK WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGIES OR TO ACQUIRE THE
SKILLS NECESSARY NECESSARY TO
TRANSITION INTO NEW JOBS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
I WILL NOW TURN THE MIKE OVER TO
OUR SPONSOR.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
MANY MISTRAL COOK I REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE THE SPONSOR OF AB -- FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY LIKE MANY
OTHER SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS TO OUR
STATE'S LOOMING -- SKILLS CRISIS --
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A SHORTAGE
OF NEARLY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
WORKERS -- THAT HAVE SKILLS TO
FIT THE JOBS THAT WILL BE
PRESENT IN THE NEXT DECADE --
AND THESE PROJECTIONS ARE ONLY
EXACERBATED BY CHANGES TO THE
INDUSTRY DUE TO NEW WAYS OF
TECHNOLOGY SO WE NEED GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY.
A CALIFORNIA MUST ADOPT PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS -- SO THAT
WE CAN GET TO AN ALL HANDS
APPROACH ON SOLVING THIS THIS
CRISIS IN AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
WAS PART OF THAT SOLUTION.
AS A MEMBER RUBIO MENTIONED THIS
IS A TAX CREDIT FOR UP SKILLED
WORKERS.
AND IT DOES BENEFIT INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE FACING A SKILLS GAP DUE
TO TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
DESTRUCTION -- IT ONLY APPLIES
TO NON HOMELY HIGHLY COMPENSATED
EMPLOYEES -- FOR MIL SKILLS JOB
TO LEAD TO STABLE MIDDLE CLASS
GOOD CAREERS -- AND THIS BENEFIT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IT IS
BENEFIT EXTENDS NOT JUST TO THE
FIRMS THAT APPLYING FOR THIS TAX
CREDIT BUT TO THE WHOLE ECONOMY.
AS SMALL MARGE MANUFACTURERS
DEVELOP PROGRAMS -- FOR THEIR
OWN FACILITIES -- USING THIS TAX
CREDIT THE THESE VALUE RESIDES
IN THE WORKER AND SO AS THAT
WORKER MOVES -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
ECONOMY -- THEY CAN CREATE AN
ENTIRE -- SECTOR INDUSTRY
VARIOUS PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THESE REASONS WHEN APPROPRIATE
RAFT FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEIA BURNLEY ON
BEHALF OF TESLA WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL WHAT ADVANCE INNOVATIVE AND
VALUABLE WORKFORCE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
A SUMMARY OF THIS.
THIS BILL I HAVE.
I HAVE ONE CLARIFYING QUESTION --
DOES THIS TAX CREDIT APPLY ONLY
TO EMPLOYERS.
THAT DO NOT ALREADY OFFER WORKER
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
NO I THINK IT WE'RE GONNA
EXTENDED TO ALL OF THE EMPLOYERS
I BELIEVE.
IS IT TOO INCENTIVIZE YES MORE
TRAINING. FOUR FOUR BUT THE MEET
THE LOW LOWER SKILLED WORKERS
THAT ARE GOING TO ADVANCE SOUL.
THE ALREADY HAVE PROGRAMS BY IF
YOU WANT SO.
IF I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
CORRECTLY SO IT WOULD APPLY TO
WE'RE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PROGRAMS ARE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO HELP OF
pSKILLED WORKERS WHERE THERE
AREN'T -- WHERE THERE MAY NOT BE
PROGRAMS THAT -- ALREADY SO EVEN
IF WORK FOR THE EMPLOYER ALREADY
HAS A TRAINING PROGRAM IT'S
APPLYING TO IN TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE MORE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO GET AT
THAT.
UPSCALING TECHNOLOGICAL.
UPWARD MOBILITY BASICALLY AND
SOME OF THE EVEN WITHIN THE
EMPLOYERS COMPANY RIGHT YES OKAY.
ONE IS A FIVE FIVE MAY ADD -- DO
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS IN MY
DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY AND I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DOING BUT
THEIR WITH SUCH AS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS -- PARTNERING UP
WITH DIFFERENT -- COMPANIES TO
OFFER THESE THESE TRAINING
PROGRAM SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
WITHIN THE THE COMPANY BUT ALSO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
DEVOUT HELPING THE COMPANIES
DEVELOP -- THESE PROGRAMS -- SO
THAT THEY CAN OFFER THE THE THE
FACILITIES BASICALLY FOR THE
TRAINING -- AND MEMBERS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE PART OF THAT
BOARD AND GIVE COULD -- THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- BASICALLY
DIRECTION AS TO WHAT
SPECIFICALLY THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
IN THE INDUSTRY SO THAT BY THE
MINUTE THE THE EMPLOYEES.
THE TRAINEES ARE ARE GRADUATED
THEY HAVE IT -- IT'S BASICALLY
MEDIA THE NEXT DAY THEY HAVE A A
BRAND NEW JOB AND SOUL SOUL
THAT'S THE TYPE OF PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS OF PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AND THE TAX CREDIT WOULD.
ENCOURAGE THOSE COMPANIES -- TO
BASICALLY PARTNER UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THEY'RE OFFERING
OR THEY'RE THEY'RE HELPING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROVIDE THOSE
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
TO THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE WE
HAVE A QUORUM IS HAVING TO CALL
THE ROLL.
YRC HERE [inaudible]
ROW EACH.
CHU GRAY MAYES MULLIN THIS
[inaudible] ONE PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE REAVIS.
BONTA WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM -- TO YOUR
QUESTION RIGHT NOW THE BILL'S
NOT CLEAR BUT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU LATER TO MOVEFOR WITH THAT.
BILLS LIKE THIS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WE DO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION WORKSHOPS ALL OVER THE
STATE -- AND THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON BUILDING A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE
AND CONNECTING BUSINESS IN ANY
WAY WE CAN WITH THE LARGE GAP AS
AND MISTER COOK.
MENTION COMING IN THE ONE POINT
FIVE TO TWO MILLION JOBS THAT
GREAT CAREERS CAREERS NOT JOBS
CAREERS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO BUY
HOMES LIKE YOUR ORIGINAL DEL --
EGGS WILL EXIST OVER THE NEXT
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS AND WE HAVE
NOT BUILT THE WORK FORCE AND
THAT IS OUR OUR MISGIVINGS AT AT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
BILLS LIKE THIS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND YOU KNOW IF IF
THERE'S ANYTHING.
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO ALSO SEE
WITHIN -- THE THE THE BILL ARE
OBVIOUSLY MY MY I AREAS VERY
DIFFERENT AND YOU KNOW THOSE OF
OF THE MEMBERS HERE AND SO
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
THAT I'VE I'VE MISSED I WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO TO IMPROVE
THE BELL SO THAT ALL OF THESE --
THE SECTIONS OF CALIFORNIA THE
BUT THE OTHER VALLEY -- CAN HAVE
JUST THE BENEFIT AS AS MY VALLEY
DOES AS WELL SO WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT WHEN
APPROPRIATE THINKING.
MOVING.
TO FAIL.
FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B. ELEVEN
SIXTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER WOULD YOU LIKE
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
FIRST WE HAVE SUBMITTED MEMBERS
TO MAKE EMPLOYEE HIRE DATE
PERSPECTIVE STARTING JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY AS REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE PROPOSES A
NEW TAX INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
THE HIRING OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THE CURRENT EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
FOR THE ID COME COMMUNITY ARE
ASTONISHING.
MORE THAN 85% OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO
RECEIVE REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES.
ARE NOT WORKING.
AND 23% OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES REMAIN
UNCERTAIN ABOUT THE COST TO
PROTECT PRODUCTIVITY OF
EMPLOYEES WITH ID DE.
A FIVE FULLY STRUCTURED TAX
CREDIT THAT COMPENSATES
QUALIFIED EMPLOYERS FOR A
PERCENTAGE OF ADDITIONAL COSTS
CAN INSPIRE.
AND REASSURE BUSINESSES TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
PEOPLE WITH ADD ARE CAPABLE KIND
AND READY TO TAKE ON ANY TASK
THAT YOU GIVE THEM.
THEY WILL SUCCEED.
THEY JUST NEED A CHANCE.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE WILL GIVE
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY.
WITH ME I HAVE A WITNESS.
WHAT'S THE WORST.
ONE OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WESLEY WESTON
AND I'M THE CHAIR OF THE PLAN
THE FIRST COMMITTEE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AT LARGE MEMBER OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON THE BALLOT
DISABILITIES.
I AM ALSO JOINED TODAY BY AL
LEWIS WHO IS STAFF AT THE STATE
COUNCIL.
OUT IS HERE TO ASSIST ME WITH
ANSWERING ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
OFFERING AB SIX FORTY NINE THE
BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN THE TAX
CODE TO CREATE AN ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDIT UP TO SIX THOUSAND
DOLLAS FOR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHO HIRE QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES EMPLOYED IN
THE COMMUNITY AT MINIMUM WAGE
ARE?
ABOVE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MINIMUM
GROWTH IN THE PLUMBER RATE.
FOR FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES DESPITE COULD PICK
CONTINUED ECONOMIC GROWTH SINCE
THE RECESSION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY REPORT
THAT THE RATE OF WORK AGE PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES A SIZE
SEVEN POINT 3%. FOR PEOPLE OF
ANY TYPE OF DISABILITY IS THIRTY
SIX POINT 8%.
HAVE BEEN PLAYED PART TIME FOR
TWENTY HOURS.
A WEEK AS PRIDE CORNER AT YOUR
HOSPITAL LOS S. IS.
TWO THOUSAND SIX WHERE CAN
PROVIDE ME WITH A SENSE OF
BELONGING AND FRIENDS.
MOST MY FRIENDS GO THE DAY
PROGRAMS HAVE MAKE LESS THAN
MINIMUM WAGE.
MY WIFE MAKE LESS TO MOVE AWAY
SHE CANNOT AFFORD TO GO OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY LIKE TO SEE A
MOVIE.
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO BE A PART
OF THE COMMUNITY.
I LIKE KNOWING I COULD TRIPLING
CONTRIBUTING AND PAYING TAXES.
BARBARA BY A SMALL TAX CREDIT TO
BUSINESSES WE CAN CREATE MORE
TAXPAYERS.
EVERY CALIFORNIA WAS DISABILITY
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK IN BECOME A TAXPAYER.
I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT IS A
POINT B. O. AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE STATE COUNCIL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EXPECT ANYTHING SAID.
NOTHING FURTHER UNLESS QUESTION
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. THREE
SANDERS SOME OF THE ARE CAN YOU
SEE PM SUPPORT CAN KILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
I'M.
IN THE ANALYSIS IT TALKS ABOUT
DOUBLE DIPPING ALLOWING THE
CREDIT AND DEDUCTION IS THAT.
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO HAVE IN
THE BILL.
YOU KNOW IF IT SEEMS TO BE AN
IMPEDIMENT WERE WILLING TO
LISTEN TO ANY.
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO NOT BE CONFLICTED SO I'D LOOK
LOVE TO LOOK INTO AND SEE WHERE
THAT'S AT GREAT THANK YOU.
SEEING AS NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MANAGER.
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE ASSEMBLY --
I'VE BEEN HIRING THE ID OF
COMMUNITY TO DO -- SERVICE
RESOLUTION IN MY DISTRICT FOR
ALL SEVEN THOUSAND GRADUATES OF
MY HIGH SCHOOLS THEY CALL LATE
IN THE DAY PREPARE FOR EACH HIGH
SCHOOL.
IT'S BEEN A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH THE
ARK IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
THEY ARE SO QUALITY ORIENTED IS
NOT EVEN FUNNY.
I JUST WANTED VANCE'S AND GIVE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO EMPLOYERS
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS AN
ISLAND.
ON OPEN TREASURE AND I THINK
THAT THIS WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITIES ALSO ADVANCE --
THE ABILITY TO IMPLY THE
EMPLOYEE THE PEOPLE WITH THE
IDEA TO COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU I THIS IS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CLOSING STATEMENTS I THINK
THEY'RE RIGHT ON THE MARK SO WE
WILL SEE YOU AND WHEN IT'S TIME
TO VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
I'M LIVING FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
TEN SO REMEMBER CHIU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LET ME
FIRST START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- WITH
REGARDS TO THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET
DATE AS WELL AS THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
AB TEN WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND EXPAND OUR STATES FOR
WHAT HOUSING TAX CREDIT BY FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- THIS
IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL ONE THAT IN
TERMS LEVERAGES ANOTHER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS LOCAL TAX CREDITS AS
WELL AS PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENTS. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE BEEN A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
THIS IS MY FIFTH TIME MOVING
FORWARD THIS BILL -- AND I WILL
EXPLAIN WHY I AM HOPEFUL THAT
THIS IS THE YEAR -- BUT I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THE LAST TIME
THIS WAS VOTED OUT FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK -- THAT WAS A. B. THIRTY
FIVE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WHEN
HIS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
THE REASON WE ARE HOPEFUL THIS
YEAR IS THAT THEN CANDIDATE NOW
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS STRONG STE
AS CHORE HAS SHOWN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING.
THIS AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET HE
HAS PROPOSED A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION HIS
RECENT PUT OUT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THIS PROPOSAL.
I AND FOR THAT REASON WE ARE
HOPEFUL SO AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
PATIENCE OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
AND HOPEFULLY THIS MIGHT BE THAT
LAST YEAR.
IN ADDITION TO INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT.
AB TEN WILL MAKE THE CREDIT MORE
VALUABLE AND INCREASE THE AMOUNT
THE TAXPAYERS WILL PAY FOR IT.
AB TEN WOULD REVISE A STATE LAW
EXEMPTING THIS FROM THE PASSIVE
ACTIVITY LOS RULES WHICH WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
EQUITY PRICING OF THIS TAX
CREDIT.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE
ABILITY OF INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS
TO CLAIM THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT BY ELIMINATING THE
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP.
ON AN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS
OFFSET FOR PASSIVE RENTAL REAL
ESTATE ACTIVITIES IN COMPUTING
TAXABLE INCOME.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING WE
HAVE MOVED FOR A LOT OF POLICIES
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS TO
ADDRESS THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
I AND MY HOPE IS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD MORE
BILLS AROUND PRODUCTION AROUND
PRESERVING HOUSING AROUND HOW WE
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE AT RISK OF BEING EVICTED
BUT THIS NEEDS TO BE A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF HOW WE SOLVE
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
AND HOW WE PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
THOSE WHO ARE DOING THE MOST
WORK? TO HELP AND ARE CRISIS SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESS.
MS WHITE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
RENO WENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM PLEASE TO
BECAUSE FUNDING THIS FOR I GUESS
THE FIFTH TIME -- AND THE ONLY
THING I WANT TO ADD IS JUST HOW
CRITICAL THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
IS TEMPORE BY HOUSING PRODUCTION
THERE IS NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ELEMENT IN THE STATE THAT I CAN
THINK OF THE DOESN'T HAVE TAX
CREDIT EQUITY AS OR THE BASE
FUNDING SOURCE AND WHILE.
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL GRATEFUL
TO LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE FOR
PASSING -- HOUSING BONDS
PREVIOUSLY A FOR PASSING A
PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALL OF THOSE
GET PAIRED WITH THE HOUSING
CREDIT.
AND WITHOUT SORT OF EXPANDING
THE POOL OF THE HOUSING CREDIT
WE CAN'T BILL WE CAN INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD --
WITHOUT A CREDIT LIKE THIS AND
SO IT REALLY CRITICAL AND
HELPFUL -- THAT THIS YEAR WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL IN OUR DRIVE UP
TODAY.
THANK YOU JUST A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
REVENUE CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PLAY JOHNSON WHO ABOUT HIS
TEACHERS A FEW ON A MOCK PROCOL
SPONSORED LEGISLATION.
BUT I THINK THIS SUMMER FOR THE
SHIP OF THE PORT ISSUE THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TONY BLAIR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT AS WELL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MARYLAND TAKE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MATCH WORDS CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THOUGHT QUIRK.
SO ARM EVER SINCE THE END OF
REDEVELOPMENT YES OKAY THANK YOU
EVER SINCE THE END OF
REDEVELOPMENT THERE'S BEEN LESS.
LOCAL MONEY GOING TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF
BRINGING REDEVELOPMENT BACK I
THINK THEY WERE TOO MANY.
ABUSES HOW AND ALTHOUGH MY
COMMUNITY ALWAYS DID IT THE
RIGHT WAY BUT EVEN SO THEY DON'T
WANT IT TO COME BACK THEY SAID
THE THE COLLAPSE OF THE
PROGRAM'S SOMETHING THEY NEVER
WANT TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH AGAIN.
NONE THE LESS THIS WOULD BE A
WAY OF GETTING MONEY THAT THE
STATE WAS ALLOCATING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BACK TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO I'M CERTAINLY IN FAVOR OF
THAT.
THE ONE COMMENT WE HAVE.
FOUR ODD THAT IN HERE IS THAT
BECAUSE IT TAX CREDIT IS WORTH
LESS THAN A DOLLAR -- WOULD IT
MAKE SENSE TO MAKE THIS A GRANT
PROGRAM I THINK THERE MAY BE A
PROBLEM THERE AND BRINGING THEM
ON THE FEDERAL MONEY IF YOU DO
THAT BUT I DON'T KNOW -- WOULD
YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SHOULD IT
BE A GRANT PROGRAM AND IF YOU
DID THAT WOULD IT BE A PROBLEM
GETTING THE FEDERAL MONEY SO THE
ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY YES THE
POINT WE STRUCTURE THIS IS TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
DOLLARS WHICH ARE VERY WELL
ESTABLISHED.
FEDERAL PROGRAM AND AND
ESSENTIALLY WE CAN LEVERAGE --
TWO OR THREE ACTS FOR EVERY
STATE DOLLARS THAT WE APPLY SO
THAT'S WHY WE STRUCTURE IT THIS
WAY AND NOW WE ALSO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
IN THIS BILL. TO INCREASE THE
VALUE OF THE TAX CREDIT SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET TO A DOLLAR
OR MORE.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THING I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. TO
SOME HALF OF THE TWO DOZEN --
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORS OF THIS THAT
REPRESENT THE POLITICAL
DIVERSITY OF THE LEGISLATURE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS THE
GEOGRAPHIC AND AND IDEOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY OF OUR LEGISLATURE.
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
HOPE WERE ABLE TO MOVE THIS ONE
LAST TIME THANK YOU.
IN A FILING FOURTEEN AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIVING.
YOU TO RECOGNIZE ME DID YOU.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX IS A BILL
THAT SOUNDS LIKE FREEDOM.
IT.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK IS.
YOU KNOW WAY BACK IN IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE STATE WAS
A FISCAL BASKET CASE I REMEMBER
THAT FROM HAVING DOUBLE DIGIT
TUITION INCREASES THAT OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
WE ALSO DECIDED. TO TAX NEWS WE
THOUGHT.
GETTING IN THE WAY OF AN
INFORMED CITIZENRY WAS A GOOD
IDEA. TO BALANCE CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR PUT A TAX ON
PRINT NEWSPAPERS.
OF COURSE ONLINE JOURNALISM IS
NOT TAXED BUT THERE IS THIS
DOUBLE STANDARD.
ON PRINT NEWS NOW OF COURSE WE
WANT LOCAL WE WANT OUR RESIDENTS
ARE CONSTITUENTS TO BE INFORMED.
AND WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET LOCAL NEWS.
AND SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
NOW THAT OUR FISCAL HOUSE IN
ORDER THAT WE WORKED REALLY HARD
THE PAST SIX YEARS TO DO THAT.
THAT WE CAN'T TAKE THIS DOUBLE
STANDARD AWAY.
AND ENDED THIS DOUBLE STANDARD
AND END OF THIS TAX ON PRINT
NEWS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
AN INFORMED CITIZENRY.
THAT IS THE POINT OF THIS BILL.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A GUEST
TO ALSO TESTIFIED.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TOM
NEWTON REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION --
CN PA IS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
YEARS OLD PLUS OR MINUS AND
REPRESENTS MOST THE DAILY
NEWSPAPERS IN THE STATE.
ABOUT SIXTY SIX ON ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE WEEKLY
NEWSPAPERS.
ANOTHER EIGHTY OR SO CAMPUS
NEWSPAPERS AND ELEVEN DIGITAL
NEWS NEWS ORGANIZATIONS WERE
OPEN TO GROW THAT NUMBER -- IN --
NINETEEN NINETY ONE FACE WITH A
HUGE DEFICIT -- FOR PREVIOUSLY
EXEMPT ITEMS WERE.
THEREAFTER TAXED NEWSPAPERS AND
PERIODICALS.
BOTTLED WATER CANDY AND SNACKS
AND BUNKER FUEL WHICH IS STORED
FUEL -- MOST OF THOSE EXEMPTIONS
HAVE BEEN PUT BACK IN PLACE AS
FAR AS NEWSPAPERS GO AND THE
ANALYSIS THAT DOES A GOOD JOB OF
POINTING THIS OUT -- TAX
EXEMPTIONS WERE PRETTY QUICKLY
PUT BACK IN PLACE FOR FREELY
DISTRIBUTED NEWSPAPERS
NEWSPAPERS CREATED BY --
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS.
AND ALSO -- AND NEWSPAPERS THAT --
OUR WEEKLY AS FAR AS SO LONG AS
THEY ARE DELIVERED BY
SUBSCRIPTION.
REALLY WHAT'S LEFT IN THE TAX IS
A TAX ON ABOUT SIXTY SIX DALY
FIRST AMENDMENT SPEAKERS.
AND THE OVER THE COUNTER.
CIRCULATION OF WEEKLY NEWSPAPERS.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE NEWS
PAPER BUSINESS WAS BOOMING --
NEWSPAPERS WERE VERY SECURE IN
THEIR POSITION IN THE ECONOMY.
AND EVERYONE KNEW THAT THEY
WOULD SURVIVE PLACING A SALES
TAX ON THEM.
SINCE THAT TIME WE DON'T HAVE TO
TALK TOO MUCH ABOUT THE
DESTRUCTION THAT'S OCCURRED --
BUT SINCE -- FOR EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED UNITED STATES NEWSPAPERS
ARE NO LONGER.
BEING PUBLISHED IN THIS COUNTRY --
WE'RE WORK ADVANCING THREE
ARGUMENTS FOR WHY THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD PASS THIS BILL.
THE FIRST IS THAT NEWSPAPERS
CONTINUE TO CREATE A COMMUNITY
FORUM.
THEY EXIST TO PROFESSIONALLY
GATHER.
AT IT.
AND CREATE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
DAILY AND WEEKLY INFORMATION.
THAT HELPS ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
BE BETTER IT HELPS OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE BETTER AND
RESEARCH BEARS THIS OUT -- A
RECENT -- NEWMAN LAB ARTICLE
JUST READ YOU THE LEAD GRAPH IT
SAYS WHAT DO STRONG LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS DO.
WELL RESEARCH SHOWS THEY
INCREASE VOTER TURNOUT REDUCE
GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION MAKE
CITIES FINANCIALLY HEALTHIER
MAKES IT IS A MOREKNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT POLITICS AND MORE LIKELY
TO ENGAGE WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
FORCE LOCAL TV TO RAISE ITS GAME
AND ENCOURAGE SPLIT TICKET AND
MORE DIVERSE VOTING -- WE
BELIEVE THAT NEWSPAPERS ARE
STILL FIGHTING. TO TO THIS ROLE
AND ARE STILL DOING IT -- THE
SECOND THING AND THIS IS BEEN
COVERED -- THE TAXES PATENTLY
UNFAIR AS IT RELATES TO ABOUT
SIXTY SIX FIRST AMENDMENT
SPEAKERS.
AS OPPOSED TO THE INTERNET AND
ALL THE SPEAKERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE -- WE'RE TAXING THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE STILL IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES CREATING.
INFORMATION FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE PUBLIC AND WE'RE EXEMPTING
THAT AGGREGATORS AND SCRAPERS
AND PROCESS ESPECIALLY THE
DUOPOLY.
THERE BECAUSE SO MUCH HAVOC --
FINALLY.
NEWSPAPERS ARE AND THEY'RE STILL
FIGHTING -- WHAT'S LEFT OF THE
NEWSPAPER BUSINESS IS STILL
ANXIOUS.
TO GET HIS FEET UNDER IT TO FIND
A NEW BUSINESS MODEL.
AND TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS. FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN THIS COMES BEFORE I WANT TO
MAKE ONE ONE MORE POINT THAT UP
FOR CLARIFICATION THIS IS A TAX
ON THE CONSUMER WHO BUYS THE
NEWSPAPER TO READ AND BECOME
INFORMED IT'S NOT A TAX ON THE
BUSINESS.
IT'S A TAX ON A PERSON WHO WANTS
TO PURCHASE THAT NEWSPAPER.
ADDITIONAL TESTS MY IN SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DARK QUIRK -- SO.
I'M NOT.
SO IN OTHER WORDS RIGHT NOW IF I
PAY SIXTY SIX DOLLARS A YEAR. TO
GET TO A NEWSPAPER I'D HAVE TO
PAY SIXTY INSTEAD.
IF THE TAX WENT DOWN -- THERE IS
A TAX APPLIED ON TO THE COST OF
THE NEWSPAPER -- I I I DON'T
KNOW BUT BASICALLY IT WOULD
REDUCE MY COST BY ABOUT 10% I'M
NOT.
I WOULD HAVE TO CLARIFY EXACTLY
WHAT THE COST OF THE TAXES WELL
RIGHT I THINK THE QUESTION IS IS
YES WITH THE TAX WITH THE
SAVINGS OF THE SALES TAX BECAUSE
YOU'RE SAYINGTHIS IS A SALES
TAX THAT CONSUMERS ARE PAYING
WITH THAT WOULD THAT SAVINGS GO
DIRECTLY. TO THE CONSUMER OR
SAYING THAT THE CHALLENGE ON
NEWSPAPERS.
THEY'RE GOING TO USE THEM TAX
MONEY THEY'RE GONNA KEEP
CHARGING THE SAME PRICE AND
SPEND THAT TAX MONEY ON OTHER
THINGS I THINK THAT OUT OF THE
CLOSET AND THE TAXES A SURCHARGE
ON THE CONSUMER.
SO PRECISELY YOUR POINT YOU
WOULD BE SAVING THE MONEY THAT
WOULD NOT SO I'D SAY SIX DOLLARS
YEAR -- MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE NO LOCAL NEWSPAPERS
AND ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SORRY TO HEAR THAT AND I I
HONESTLY THINK WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
GIVEN THE CORPORATE STRUCTURE IS
THEY JUST KEEP FEET SIXTY SIX
DOLLARS AND KEEP THE SIX DOLLARS --
WE USED TO HAVE SIX REPORTERS IN
HAYWARD NOW WE GET A HALF OF
REPORTER EVERY OTHER MONTH -- I
I JUST DON'T THINK IT THIS WOULD
BRING IT BACK BUT I'M STILL
WILLING TO CONSIDER THE BELL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
IN THE COMMITTEE.
I A I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
QUALITY NEWSPAPERS -- BUT I
THINK MY QUESTION IS THE SAME IS
THAT IS THIS SOMETHING WE'RE
GOING TO PASS ON I I I'M GETTING
KIND OF CONFLICTING MESSAGES ONE
IS SAYING THAT THE SALES TAX IS
PART OF THE DEMISE OF THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PAPERS THAT
HAVE GONE OUT OF BUSINESS.
BUT I'M ALSO GETTING THE MESSAGE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT SALES TAX IS NO LONGER
PAID BY THE CONSUMER.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE PASSED TO
THE CONSUMER AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A LITTLE CONFUSION THERE
AND AT SOME POINT IT WOULD BE
GREAT SINCE IS THIS TESTIMONY
ONLY FOR US TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION AND CLARIFY --
EXACTLY WHAT THE INTENT IS A
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE RESPECT FOR
QUALITY NEWSPAPERS AND I DO WANT
TO SEE THEM THRIVE BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND AS A COMMITTEE WHAT
THE GOALS ARE.
IS THE GOAL TO PASS THAT BACK ON
TO ROUTE TO CONSUMERS OR IS THE
GOAL TO TAKE THAT MONEY AND
INVESTED IN SOME OTHER WAY WITH
NEWSPAPERS [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO SINCE
THIS IS TESTIMONY ONLY AND NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME TO WORK OUT
SOME OF THESE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE HEARING IT.
SHOW -- IT'S A MARKET BASED
DECISION RIGHT AND AND EVERY
CONSUMER OF NEWS HAS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY THE AMOUNT.
OF THE PRINT SUBSCRIPTION.
OR PURCHASE THE OVER COUNTER
OVER THE COUNTER COPY -- THE
TAXES ADDED TO THAT.
IF THE TAX IS REPEALED.
EACH NEWSPAPER.
IS GOING TO HAVE TO DETERMINE --
HOW IT PRICES IT'S NEWSPAPERS
GOING FORWARD I SUSPECT THAT
MOST NEWSPAPERS WILL -- GIVE
THAT MONEY BACK TO THE CONSUMER
BY LOWERING THEIR BETTER PRICE
BUT I CAN'T SAY THAT -- WITH
EXACTITUDE AND IN FACT -- I
SUSPECT THAT SOME NEWSPAPERS
WOULD LOVE TO RE EMPLOY.
SOME OF THE LARGE NUMBER OF
REPORTERS THAT ARE NO LONGER
DOING THAT JOB.
AN END TO THAT THE LITTLE BIT OF
THAT POINT THE AMOUNT OF TAX
REVENUE HAS.
BEEN DECIMATED -- IN THE COURSE
OF THE PAST TWENTY YEARS -- IT'S
A FRACTION OF WHAT WAS ONCE
COLLECTED.
ANY OTHER REASON.
SO ESSENTIALLY IT WILL BE UP TO
THE INDIVIDUAL NEWSPAPER WHETHER
OR NOT THEY LEAVE THE PRICE
WHERE IT IS OUR RETURN THAT THAT.
PORTION TO THE CONSUMER -- OKAY
SO.
I APOLOGIZE I HAD ANOTHER
COMMITTEE THAT I HAD TO BE
PRESIDENT'S I MISSED MOST OF THE
CONVERSATION BUT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THAT THE THE TAX WOULD
BE.
TAKEN AWAY WHICH WOULD BE A
SAVINGS TO THE CUSTOMER RIGHT.
AND THE CONCERN IS THOUGH THAT
NEWSPAPERS WELL KEEP THE PRICE
THE SAME IF THE PAPERS FOR
DOLLARS -- IN THE TALES TAXES
TAKEN AWAY IT WILL THE NEWSPAPER
TO GET TO KEEP IT FOR DOLLARS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S USED TO
PAYING FOUR DOLLARS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THAT THAT'S THE FEAR THAT I AND
THAT.
OKAY YEAH AND SO THAT'S
CERTAINLY.
ONE ONE POTENTIAL OUTCOME -- I
THINK EACH OF THE NEWSPAPERS
WILL DEAL WITH THAT THEIR OWN
WAY BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
MANY WOULD LOVE TO INVEST.
SOME OF THAT REVENUE BACK INTO
THEIR COMMUNITY.
BY EMPLOYING.
NEWS GATHERERS TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY -- SO WHAT I'M HEARING
IS AS A RESULT OF THE REDUCTION
OF SUBSCRIPTIONS THE PAIR FOLKS
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF THE HOPE IS
THAT SOME WILL USE SOME OF THE
SALES TAX TO PUT WERE WHAT THAT
SPACE LOOKS LIKE IN TO RE
EMPLOYING SOME OF THE OLD
REPORTERS WHILE OTHERS.
WILL RETURN THAT COST TO AT THE
CUSTOMERS BUT THAT'S ON IN THE
BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN TODAY --
ALL RIGHTS AS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
EVERYONE'S CLEAR.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH SURE THANK YOU AGAIN
MANAGER THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR
THE THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET.
GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE WAY OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A A A A
CONSTITUENT A CALIFORNIAN AND
THEIR ACCESS TO LOCAL NEWS AT A
TIME.
WHEN -- A QUITE FRANKLY THERE
ARE A LOT OF POLITICIANS WHO ARE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE NEWS
THAT WE RECEIVE AND AT IT MY
HOPE IS THAT WE CAN BOLSTER THAT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THOSE WHO
GATHER AND REPORT LOCAL NEWS AND
THOSE WHO NEED. TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS IN SOCIETY THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
MOVING A FILE I AM NINE AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REAVIS WHICH YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I APPRECIATE --
THE CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL --
I'VE SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS TO
CORRECT A SLIGHT DRAFTING ERROR
IN THE BILL OF THE STATE'S NEW
MARKETS TAX CREDIT SHOULD BE IN
LINE WITH THE FEDERAL -- NEW
MARKETS TAX CREDIT AT 39% AND
NOT 43% -- TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
THAT SEEKS TO SOLVE THE STATE'S
GROWING DISPARITIES AMONG
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS OF
POPULATION GROUPS.
AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE WOULD
CREATE A STATE NEW MARKETS TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM MODELED OFF THE
SUCCESSFUL FEDERAL AN MTC
PROGRAM. TO ATTRACT INVESTMENT
FROM PRIVATE INVESTORS TO
REVITALIZE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES.
THE STATE'S NMTC PROGRAM AND
FUNDS WILL BE CREATED AND
ADMINISTERED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT --
GLOBUS.
UNDER THIS MEASURE GOBIZ WILL
ALLOW FOR COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ENTITIES WHO CAN DEMONSTRATE THE
ABILITY TO UNDERTAKE BUSINESSES
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENTS IN
LOW INCOME AREAS.
OF THE STATE TO APPLY FOR THESE
TAX CREDITS.
WELL WE ALREADY HAVE A FEDERAL
AN MTC THIS BILL WILL GIVE
CITIES ACROSS THE NATION THE
OPTION TO UTILIZE OF FEDERAL AND
STATE TAX CREDIT.
AND QUALIFYING OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS THAT FURTHER INCENTIVIZE.
THESE FINANCES TO INVEST IN
POWER AND REVITALIZED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
UNDER THIS BILL GOBIZ IS ALSO
AUTHORIZED TO DESIGNATE
QUALIFIED EQUITY INVESTMENTS.
A TWO UP.
UNDER MILLION PER TAX YEAR TO
QUALIFIED CD'S TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM.
AS A STATE WE MUST DEPLOY
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO INVEST.
TO PROCURE THE REWARDS AB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE WILL HELP FURTHER THE
STATE SCHOOL AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BY CREATING JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WHILE
GENERATING ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
FOR THE STATE -- THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND I HAVE -- SOMEONE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
AND THAT SOMEONE IS LAURIE
CHAMAR WITH SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND AB SPEAKER
MATTER CHAIR I THOUGHT THAT WAS
GREAT THAT THAT'S THAT TELLS YOU
SOMETHING -- WE'RE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA WORKS VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS WITH KOBE IS --
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
DEFINITELY HELP -- THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN THE A
CENTRAL COAST I KNOW THAT -- THE
DIRECTOR LINIMENT ALSO HAS SAID
THAT HE'D LIKE TO REALLY DEVELOP
THAT AREA IN THE CENTRAL COAST --
SO WE THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
DEFINITELY -- HELP THE
BUSINESSES IN THAT AREA THANK
YOU ARCHER SUPPORT PLEASE THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN IN COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
WHICH LIKE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM OF
FIVE
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
INSURES THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
BUSINESSES ARE NOT DOUBLE TAXED
WHEN ENGAGING WITH BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS.
IN ORDER TO AVOID PAYING TAXES
ON THE SAME INCOME IN MULTIPLE
STATES CALIFORNIA GENERALLY
ALLOWS AND OTHER STATE TAX
CREDIT FOR TAXES PAID TO OTHER
STATES.
THE OS T. C. ENSURES THAT
RESIDENT FAMILY BUSINESSES ARE
NOT DOUBLE TAXED AND COULD TAKE
CREDIT FOR THEIR SHARE OF TAXES
PAID TO OTHER STATES WHEN THOSE
TAXES ARE MEASURED BY GROSS OR
NET INCOME.
AND THE SAME ARRANGEMENT
ACTUALLY THIS KIND OF AT A
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES.
RECENTLY THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ISSUED A NEW GUIDANCE THAT
DENIES ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
A TAX CREDIT FOR TAXES PAID. FOR
THE REVISED TEXAS MARGINS TAX
WILL CALL THAT THE R. T. F. T..
SINCE TEXAS DOES NOT HAVE INCOME
TAXES FAMILY BUSINESSES HAVE
RELIED ON THE LONG HELD
UNDERSTANDING WITHIN CALIFORNIA
THAT THE R. T. F. T. IS TREATED
THE SAME AS A TRADITIONAL INCOME
TAX.
AND THEREFORE LIES A RESIDENT
FAMILY BUSINESS TO CLAIM THE O.
S. T. C..
TEXAS LAW ALLOWS FOR TAXPAYERS
TO DETERMINE THEIR TEXAS TAX
OBLIGATION BASED ON ONE OF
SEVERAL METHODOLOGIES.
THE F. T. B. I. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ISSUED A REVISED
INTERPRETATION AND NOW.
THAT INTERPRETATION SAYS THAT
BECAUSE DIFFERENT TAXPAYERS
COULD DETERMINE THEIR TAX BURDEN
DIFFERENTLY.
A SUB CHAPTER S. CORPORATION
COULD NOT RECEIVE THE O. S. T.
C.. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD ACTUALLY NOW ROLL BACK
THAT RULING MADE BY THE F. T. B.
AND ALLOW FAMILY BUSINESSES TO
CONTINUE OPERATING AS THEY WERE.
BY CLARIFYING THE TAXES PAID TO
ANOTHER STATE BE DETERMINED BY
THE ACTUAL METHOD USED TO
CALCULATE THE TAX WITHOUT REGARD.
TO METHODS ALLOWED BY THE OTHER
STATES.
I I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT AND DIVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ANALYSIS AND WILL
WERE WORKING TEN MEN THE BELL TO
INCLUDE A SUNSET DATE AND AS THE
ADDITIONAL MEASURES IN SECTION.
FORTY ONE I AND I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE TO SUPPORTERS HERE TO
TESTIFY DENNIS ALLEY ANI FROM
THE PANELISTS FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION.
AND A SLIPPER FROM BACK TELL.
I'LL BE THE FIRST OF TEAM DENNIS
TO START.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS ALBION
ARABS AND FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIAN WITH
THE SPONSORS A. B..
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT WELL TAX LAW
CAN OFTEN GET VERY DOWN ON THE
WEEK VERY QUICKLY WHAT WHAT AB
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT BASICALLY
DOES IS THE CONSISTENT POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA'S NOT TO DOUBLE TAX.
INCOME TAX OF FROM OTHER STATES
SO THAT'S WHY THEY CREATED THE
OTHER STATE TAX CREDIT.
MANY FAMILY BUSINESSES ARE
PASSED THROUGH OUR STRUCTURE TO
PASS THROUGH ORGANIZATIONS AND
SPECIFICALLY IN TWENTY TEN THE
STATE OF TEXAS MADE CHANGES TO
ITS TAXATION SYSTEM.
OF FOLLOWING THOSE CHANGES TAXES
PAID WERE TREATED AS INCOME TAX
SO SO AT THAT TIME IT WAS INCOME
TAX [inaudible]
OF AND THEN A TWENTY SIXTEEN
AFTER DEEMED STAFF PROVIDED A
NEW INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW.
SUBJECT TO MANY THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
THAT HAVE OPERATIONS IN TEXAS.
TO PAY -- DOT BASICALLY DOUBLE
TAXATION.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE USING
A METHODOLOGY OF TAX PAYMENT.
THAT WAS AN INCOME TAX BECAUSE
SOME TAXPAYER OUT THERE COULD
USE A DIFFERENT -- CHOICE OF OF
PAYING THEIR TAXES -- TO TEXAS.
THEY DISQUALIFIED THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WHOSE PAINT ON AN
INCOME TAX SO THAT'S THE GIST OF
IT -- WE HAVE BEEN -- CONVERSE
WITH F. T. V. THAN GOING BACK
AND FORTH ON SOME OF THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT AND
AND THAT.
AND BUT THEY DID BRING UP A
COUPLE POINTS IN A JUST. ONE TO
ADDRESS THEM SO THAT THEY ARE
AND I AND I KNOW WHEN WE TALK TO
SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS THEY
BROUGHT UP ALMOST GO.
SO WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE SCOPE
OF THIS -- POTENTIAL -- AREA SO
WHAT WELL THAT'D FTV BROUGHT
THAT UP IS CONCERNED.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE THEY
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT HAVE THE
NUMBERS TO KNOW HOW MANY FOLKS.
FROM TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN ACTUALLY QUALIFIED FOR
THE S. T. C..
AND THEN AFTER TWENTY SIXTEEN
DON'T QUALIFY FOR SO UP WE WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WORK
WOULD HAVE TO BE TO GET THAT
THAT -- DELINEATED BUT AT THIS
POINT WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT -- AS THEY HAVE THE DATA
AND AND AS WE WHATNOT SO -- BUT
WE DO WANT TO SAY THAT THAT
THAT'S BEEN.
WE ARGUE THAT IT'S THAT IT
WOULDN'T COST ANYTHING BECAUSE
THE FACT THAT FROM TEN IT WAS
THE LAW TO SIXTEEN AND STABBED
HER PATIENT.
PUT THAT AND WE JUST BE GOING
BACK TO THE WAY IT WAS.
BEFORE THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ACOSTA
AFTER PETITION.
SO THAT'S THE SCOPE -- ONE OTHER
ISSUE -- IS THE TALKED ABOUT
THAT THIS WOULD CHANGE THE LAW
THE THE THE THE THE LAW.
THE LAW THE INTERPRETATIONS AND
THE FACT IS THIS WOULD RELY ON
ALL THE THE THE COURT CASES AND
ALL THE DEFINITIONS THERE'S NO
CHANGING DEFINITIONS -- OF
ANYTHING AT THIS POINT IT JUST
ALLOWS.
FOR WHEN YOU DO WITH THE INCOME
TAX TO BE ABLE TO APPLY THAT IF
YOU PAY THAT WAY TO THE ACTUAL
WAY YOU YOU APPLY YOUR TAX SO.
THOSE ARE A COUPLE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP I THOUGHT I
WOULD DRESS AND I'LL TURN OVER
THE MISTER LOW.
FOR A DENTIST Là PRODUCTO LACED
S. CORPORATION.
BASICALLY WHAT MISTER ROBINSON
IS IS THE MOST RELEVANT THERE'S
BEEN NOTHING SINCE THE ORIGINAL.
HAVE TO BE -- A GUIDANCE AND AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THERE'S BEEN
NO CHANGE WHATSOEVER IN THE LAW
THERE'S BEEN NO CHANGE IN COURT
DECISION SINCE AT THAT TIME.
SO SOMEBODY HAD AN EPIPHANY IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
REVERSED -- WITH THE TAXPAYERS
OF KNOWING FOR ALL THOSE YEARS
OF MAKES NO SENSE -- SO BECAUSE
OF THE FLIP UP WE THINK IT NEEDS
GUIDANCE OF THE OF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE RATHER
THAN.
LETTING BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT LEGAL WOULD DO AND AGAIN
AND TEN MORE YEARS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS MASTERS.
FOR WHAT ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION XENON
COMES IN QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK -- SO.
THIS IS OF COURSE FAIRLY
CONFUSING BUT ONE OF THE
COMMENTS -- BY STAFF.
IS THAT THE TEXAS TAX IS MUCH
LIKE.
TAXES IN OTHER STATES WHICH ARE
NOT TREATED AS INCOME TAXES THAT
IN FACT IT'S A TAX ON GROSS
RECEIPTS RATHER THAN ON INCOME --
IS THAT CORRECT.
THE TEXAS TAX HAS THREE METHODS
ONE OF THOSE METHODS WHICH WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IN WHICH THE
TAXPAYERS USUALLY ADDRESS IS THE
COST OF GOODS SOLD FOR WHICH
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
AGREES IS A INCOME TAX OR GROSS
INCOME.
YEAH THERE IS NOT A CONTROVERSY
FOR WITH FTV THAT THAT THAT IF
YOU USE COST OF GOODS SOLD THAT
THAT ISN'T AN INCOME TAX.
WHY IS COST OF GOODS SOLD IN
INCOME TAX YOU CAN SELL THINGS
AND HAVE NO INCOME?
BECAUSE YOUR COSTS ARE GREATER
[inaudible]
I THINK.
YOUR METHODOLOGY FOR CALCULATING
PROFIT BASE AND COST OF GOODS
SOLD. OH OH OKAY FINE.
ALL RIGHT SO THERE IS A WAY THAT
THIS CAN BE AN INCOME TAX IN
TEXAS [inaudible]
YES.
BUT YOU GET TO CHOOSE WHETHER
IT'S IN INCOME TAX OR ANOTHER
KIND OF TAX.
YES THE THE THE ACTUALLY TEXAS
LAW.
IS DOES NOT ALLOW FOR SPECIFIC
INCOME TAX BUT RECOGNIZES AS THE
COST OF GOODS SOLD OF METHOD OF
CALCULATING THE TAX AS AN AS IS
BASICALLY TAXES SO BASICALLY
IT'S TAXING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
WHAT IT COST YOU TO PRODUCE THE
GOOD AND WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AND?
IN.
AND WHEN YOU SALAS IS THAT WHAT
IT DOES.
SO THAT'S ONE WAY THEY CAN TAX
AND THEN THEY HAVE OTHER WAYS
THEY CAN TAX.
IN A COMPANY CAN CHOOSE WHICH
WAY IT WANTS TO DO IT PROBABLY
BASED UPON -- WHAT'S MOST
FAVORABLE TO THEM.
IS THAT CORRECT.
AFTER THREE DIFFERENT WAYS OF
DOING IT.
YOUR CONSULT CAN ANSWER THAT
BETTER THAN I CAN ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS CONFUSING.
THE GOAL IS JUST TO ENSURE THAT.
YOU WHETHER YOU ARE SELLING
TEXAS OR SELLING PRODUCTS IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND MAKING.
A PROFIT THERE THAT THE WAY THAT
THE TAXATION IS TREATED.
IS UNIFORMS AND FAIR AND THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE A POLICY OF DOUBLE
TAXATION.
FOR IF ANY OF RIGHT AND AND I
AGREE WITH THAT THE PROBLEM IS
THE F. T. V..
HAS PEOPLE WHO PROBABLY DO
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL AND LIKE
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM EXCEPT
PERHAPS FOR COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THEY VIEWED IT AS NOT AND SO
I I'M JUST I NEED A LOT MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE I COULD VOTE
ON THIS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR TV I THINK TO TO
CLARIFY SOME OF THE DISCREPANCY
I THINK BETWEEN.
THEIR UNDERSTANDING AND AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING I THINK RIGHT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS.
IN MY MIND IS THAT THERE WAS AN
INTERPRETATION CHANGE THAT WAS
MADE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
AS WE HIGHLIGHTED.
THAT WAS NOT PROMPTED BY ANY
LEGISLATIVE ACTION READY TO
SERVE EXECUTIVE ACTION IT IT WAS
JUST A RE INTERPRETATION YEAH
BUT THEY'RE SAYING THAT'S MORE
IN LINE WITH WHAT THEY'RE DOING
FOR OTHER STATES.
AND ARE WE GONNA HAVE AN A A
BILL ON INDIANA TAX NEXT -- SO I
JUST NEED TO UNDERSTAND A LOT
MORE.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK I THINK THAT WE I THINK
THAT.
I ALSO WOULD JUST LIKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE I KNOW WE'RE WORKING ON
WITH THE UNIVERSE LOOKS LIKE.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT WITH
THE NEW INTERPRETATION OR THE
INTERPRETATION AS IT STANDS NOW
I UNDERSTAND IT WAS A CHANGE AND
THAT IT WAS GO IT'S GOING BACK I
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THAT.
BUT I THINK WE STILL WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE UNIVERSE IS
IS THIS A BILL FOR SIX PEOPLE OR
IS THIS ACTUALLY LIKE A FAMILY
OUR ESTIMATE NOW AND WHERE I
LIVE.
AGAIN STILL CLICK CONFIRMING
THIS THAT THE FTV BUT THE
CURRENT ESTIMATE IS THAT IT'S
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES
THAT WOULD SUBSTANTIVELY THAT
ARE BEING SUBSTANTIVELY
PENALIZED BY THIS
REINTERPRETATION.
AND I IN THAT AREA OF ABOUT.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED HERE AROUND A THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR LESS.
ALL RIGHT I THINK THAT'S THE
FIRST WE FOR THAT I THINK YOU.
ON ANY WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
AS I SAID I THINK THE THE
OBJECTIVE WITH THIS SPELL IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
FAIR AND CONSISTENT HI TAX
POLICY THAT TREATS EARNINGS IN
TEXAS THE SAME AS IT TREATS
EARNINGS.
ANYWHERE IN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND WILL CERTAINLY
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THEY HAVE TO BE IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP TO ENSURE
THAT.
BEFORE WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ANYTHING IT'S VERY CLEAR WHAT
WE ARE.
ALL VOTING.
THANK YOU SO I THINK THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE EVERYONE HERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
REGULAR BUSINESS AND VOTES ON
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTEEN DO I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND IS
HIGHLY TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BURKE I
WORK ON A BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO CHIU. TWO I GRAY.
GRAY I'M MAYES [inaudible]
LANDIS ONE THIS NOW MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
AND ITEM FIFTEEN YEAH YEAH.
PETRIE-NORRIS NO QUIRK YES QUIRK
AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE BONTA.
BONTA I THAT BILL.
THE BILL HAS PASSED MOVING A
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
TEN FORTY NINE CAN I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
AND A MOTION AND A SECOND THIS
HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GOOD QUESTION -- THE QUESTION IS
IF THE CITY WERE TO PURCHASE AS
A GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION THAT
HAS A REGULAR FIRE DEPARTMENT
PAID PEOPLE IF THEY PURCHASE
THIS KIND OF EQUIPMENT DID THEY
HAVE TO PAY A SALES TAX.
YES.
THEY DO THIS JUST FOR VOLUNTEER
THIS IS JUST A VOLUNTEER OKAY
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
ARI BRO.
BRO RHU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MAYES MULLIN THIS
LENDERS ARE A MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
I QUIRK NOT VOTING QUIRK NOT
VOTING REAVIS.
RIVERSIDE BONTA.
BONTA.
THAT MEASURE IS PASSED MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THREE FOR TESTIMONY
ONLY AB SIXTY SIX MISCONDUCT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR WOMAN I AM BACK
WITH MY YEARLY ATTEMPT TO MAKE
DIAPERS TAX FREE -- AS WE KNOW
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A POLICY
OF TAXING THINGS THAT ARE HEALTH
NECESSITIES OF WHICH DIAPERS ARE.
BEYOND THAT -- WE KNOW THAT ONE
IN THREE FAMILIES NATIONWIDE
STRUGGLE THEY ADMIT TO
STRUGGLING AND NOT USING OF A
CORRECT AMOUNT OF DIAPERS ON
THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE OF DIAPERS.
THE COST TO DIAPER A CHILD
RANGES FROM ABOUT A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH PROBABLY.
MR MULLIN PAYS MORE THAN THAT
WITH TWO CHILDREN -- AND THE TAX
ON THOSE DIAPERS THEN. FOR THE
YEAR IS ENOUGH TO PAY FOR A FULL
MONTH SUPPLY OF DIAPERS SO THIS
IS AN INCONSEQUENTIAL IT'S NOT --
TO DO SOMETHING BECAUSE IT FEELS
GOOD IT'S TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE WE DESPERATELY NEED IT.
I IN CALIFORNIA ALONE OVER 60%
OF CHILDREN ARE BORN INTO
POVERTY.
ABOUT THAT NUMBER ARE BORN ON
MEDI CAL AND IF YOU LOOK AT
CHILDREN WHO ARE BROWN AND BLACK
THAT NUMBER GOES UP TO ABOUT TWO
THIRDS.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT MOST BABIES WE KNOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE BORN
INTO FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING --
TO PAY THE BILLS AND THOSE WHO
AREN'T -- THOSE WHO ARE KIND OF
IN THE MIDDLE CLASS WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THEM AS WELL BECAUSE THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE USUALLY
DESIGNATOR TO HELP WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES AND POOR FAMILIES.
BUT THE MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
WHO -- ARE OFTEN THE MOST
VULNERABLE TIME ECONOMICALLY AND
ARE HAVING YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
ALSO AFFECTED BY THE COST OF
DIAPERS AND SO OBVIOUSLY -- TO
RELIEVE TAXES IN A WAY THAT
WOULD FOR A FILL A FULL MONTH'S
SUPPLY OF DIAPERS A SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE HELPFUL TO A VAST
MAJORITY AN OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS.
I THINK THIS IS -- AN IMPORTANT
FEATURE BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST A
AYE DESIGNATION OF SOMETHING
THAT -- WE KNOW SHOULD BE DONE
IT ACTUALLY HELPS INDIVIDUALS
AND I HAVE BEEN TOLD TIME AND
TIME AGAIN -- THAT I SHOULD GO
LOOK AT OTHER WAYS TO HELP
PEOPLE A DIAPER NEED AND WE'VE
DONE JUST THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
PASS THE FIRST IN THE NATION.
EFFORTS TO HELP US --
INDIVIDUALS ON CAL WORKS OBTAIN
DIAPER SO THAT THEY CAN PUT
THEIR CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE AND
GET A JOB OR GO TO SCHOOL THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE KIDS AND UNDERSTAND.
THE YOU CANNOT SEND YOUR CHILD
TO CHILD CARE WITHOUT EIGHT OR
TEN DIAPERS FOR THE DAY -- WE
HAD TREMENDOUS STORIES OF WOMEN
WHO HAD FINALLY GOTTEN
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE HAD FOUND
THEMSELVES A JOB SHOWED UP THE
FIRST DAY IN COULD NOT DROP
THEIR CHILD OFF BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE AN EXTRA EIGHT TO TEN
DIAPERS.
WE ALLEVIATED THAT PROBLEM
THROUGH -- THROUGH A CAL WORKS
AND THERE IS NOW AN ABILITY TO
GET UP TO THIRTY DIAPERS THIRTY
DOLLARS WORTH OF DIAPERS FOR THE
MONTH THAT'S A POSITIVE IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
LAST YEAR WE ALLOCATED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS STATEWIDE FOR
THREE YEARS TO DO PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FOUR AREAS THE
STATE THAT CURRENTLY HAVE DIAPER
BANKS DIAPERED BANKS THAT ARE A
CO JOINED WITH FOOD BANKS.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT ALSO HELPS IT
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS LIKE LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO
AND FRESNO WHERE THOSE
ALLOCATIONS ARE BEING MADE.
THEY'RE STILL FAR TOO MANY
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T
HAVE THAT EXTRA THE RELIEF THE
ONLY WAY TO PROVIDE THAT RELIEF
WHOLESALE ACROSS THE STATE IS TO
START WITH DIAPER TAX.
THE FACT THE DIAPERS ARE JUST
TOO EXPENSIVE AND I BERNIE
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM CAN BE
IT CAN AT LEAST START TO BE
ALLEVIATED BY REMOVING THE
DIAPER TAX WITH THAT I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES.
AND HI THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ.
AT MADAM CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
I'M NOR WIND STEEN CO PRESIDENT
OF BABY BABY A LOS ANGELES BASED
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES CHILDREN
IN POVERTY WITH DIAPERS CLOTHING
AND ALL THE BASIC NECESSITIES
THAT EVERY CHILD DESERVES.
WE'VE DISTRIBUTED FIFTY MILLION
ITEMS INCLUDING TWENTY NINE
MILLION DIAPERS OVER THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN.
OUR BABY BABY BOARD AMBASSADORS
AN INCREDIBLE GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA BASED MOTHERS
INCLUDING JESSICA ALBA KERRY
WASHINGTON AMY ADAMS KELLY
ROWLAND KRISTEN BELL WHO SUPPORT
OUR WORK EACH DAY.
JUST LAST MONTH OUR BOARD MEMBER
JULIE BOW ENJOYING IN SACRAMENTO
TO SPEAK TO THE GOVERNOR TO
GOVERNOR NEW SEVEN OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS.
ABOUT THIS BILL. ONE IN THREE
FAMILIES IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
STRUGGLING TO AFFORD DIAPERS
WHEN WE ASK A MOM A DAD OR A
SOCIAL WORKER IN OUR PROGRAM
WHAT THEY NEED MOST.
THE FIRST SECOND AND THIRD THING
THEY SAY IS DIAPERS.
HARD WORKING MOTHERS IN OUR
PROGRAM ARE LITERALLY EMPTYING
OUT THEIR DISPOSABLE DIAPERS
HANGING THEM TO DRY AND RE USING
THEM ON THEIR BABIES.
SO WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF
JIMMY'S A MOTHER WE SERVE.
WHO IS HOMELESS AND FORCED TO
KEEP PERCENT RJ IN THE SAME
DIAPER FOR DAYS AT A TIME?
WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF RE ANY
SHOT A MOTHER IN INGLEWOOD AND
YOUR DISTRICT MADAM CHAIR WHO
WAS LIVING IN HER CAR INTO WE
GAVE HER DIAPERS AND SHE COULD
USE THAT EXTRA MONEY TO GIVE TO
MAKE HER RENT.
WE'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF A LOVELY
YOUNG WOMAN WHO WORKS AT THE
STATE HOUSE EATERY DOWNSTAIRS.
WHO WHO WHO WAS THRILLED TO
LEARN THAT THIS BILL WAS BEING
HEARD BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH SHE
HAS A STEADY JOB THE COST OF
DIAPERS IS MAKING HER LIFE THAT
MUCH HARDER?
THIS IS BECAUSE DIAPERS ARE
EXPENSIVE IN THE MOST SHOCKING
PART IS THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
REQUIRING A FULL DAY'S SUPPLY OF
DIAPERS FOR CHILDREN TO ATTEND.
CREATING A BARRIER FOR MOMS IN
OUR PROGRAM TO REENTER THE
WORKFORCE.
A LIMITED TAX FROM DIAPERS CAN
HELP BREAK A VICIOUS CYCLE OF
POVERTY WHEN THE FAMILIES WE
SERVE HAVE DRY DIAPERS.
THEY CAN RETURN TO WORK AND GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET.
CURRENTLY EIGHT STATES INCLUDING
NEW YORK HAVE ELIMINATED THE
SALES TAX ON DIAPERS AND
CALIFORNIA OUR HOME STATE.
WITH THE HIGHEST RATE OF CHILD
POVERTY IN THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO
JOIN THEM SO ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE FAMILIES IN POVERTY WE SERVE.
AND ALL OF THE FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING AB.
SIXTY SIX ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
I NAME AND AFFILIATION.
SORRY FOR THE HURT A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
STILL VANDER CLAY -- I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY GOVERNMENT
LICENSE WITH THE NATIONAL DIAPER
BANK NETWORK -- SO OUR NETWORK
REPRESENTS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
DIAPER BANKS NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING FIFTEEN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- THAT SERVE FORTY
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN EACH
MONTH -- THESE NONPROFIT PROGRAM
SISTER BE MORE THAN TWELVE POINT
FOUR MILLION FREE DIAPERS EACH
YEAR TO CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
LIVING IN POVERTY -- AND ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL BY
BURBANK NETWORK I FIRST LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FOR HER.
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO ENDING
DIAPER NEED -- CAM TRAILBLAZING
LEGISLATION IS REALLY BEEN AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- RENOWNED NOT
JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
A ACROSS THE COUNTRY -- AND OR
OR CERTAINLY ALL BETTER FOR IT
SO THANK YOU -- AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON ENDING CHILD POVERTY -- OF
WHICH DIAPER NEED IS OFTEN A
HITTING CONSEQUENCE SO THE
NATIONAL DIAPER BANK IS PROUD TO
SUPPORT YOUR AB -- TWENTY FOUR
AS PART OF THAT BOLD INITIATIVES
SUCH AS AB TWENTY FOUR NAVY --
SIXTY SIX WILL REALLY HELP
STRUGGLING FAMILIES LIVING A
PARTY BE ABLE TO SECURE THE
BASIC NECESSITIES LIKE DIAPERS
REQUIRED FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO
THRIVE -- ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
REFERENCED EARLIER THAT WE
CONDUCTED WITH IT AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH RESEARCHERS AT
YALE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE ONE IN
THREE FAMILY STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE
ENOUGH DIAPERS TO KEEP THEIR
BABY.
CLEAN DRY AND HEALTHY AND SO
THIS IS WHAT IS KNOWN AS AS
DIAPER NEED AND AS NORA --
MENTIONED EARLIER PARENTS OFTEN
HAVE TO TAKE ACTIONS TO PROLONG --
THEIR USE OF DISPOSABLE DIAPERS
AND THESE ACTIONS BORN OUT OF
UNFORTUNATE NECESSITY CAN LEAD
TO DIAPER DERMATITIS URINARY
TRACT INFECTIONS AND OTHER
CONDITIONS -- THAT MAY REQUIRE
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE AND EXPENSES --
DIAPERS ARE REALLY TRULY HAVE A
BASIC NECESSITY AND SO BY
EXEMPTING DIAPERS FROM THE SALES
TAX.
AB SIXTY SIX LINES OF
CALIFORNIA'S BROADER SALES TAX
POLICY BUT REALLY MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL PUTS MONEY
BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF ALL
FAMILIES.
HELPING THEM BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
GIVING THEM EXTRA MONEY TO
INVEST IN THEIR CHILD'S FUTURE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY SEE IS
SO IMPORTANT HERE.
AS THE NATIONAL DEBT -- NATIONAL
NETWORK WE ALSO SEE THE IMPACT
THAT THIS BILL COULD NOT ONLY
HAVING CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY -- CALIFORNIA
IS A POLICY LEADER AND A TREND
SETTERS SO WHAT HAPPENS HERE IN
THESE HALLS.
THE CHANGES ARE THE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING IN DC
AND ANOTHER STATE LEGISLATURES
AND WE'VE REALLY SEEN THAT
HAPPENING -- FOR INSTANCE WITH
THE COW WORKS -- STIPEND FOR
DIAPERS CONNECTICUT IS WORKING
ON IMPLEMENTING A VERY SIMILAR
THING IN THIS DIRECTOR BECAUSE
OF THE WORK THAT'S HAPPENED HERE --
AND SO BY PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
SEVEN EXAMPLE FOR THE REST THE
COUNTRY.
PAVE THE WAY FOR MORE STATES TO
INVEST IN ENDING DIAPER NEED --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EDITION OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IMMENSELY.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HERE MARIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
JUST BIRTH LOW WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
CLEAR LIP SHILTS NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DR -- THIS IS AN HONEST QUESTION
SO I WAS THE OLDEST TO SEVEN
RAISED IN THE FIFTIES AND
FORTIES -- AND WE HAD CLOTH
DIAPERS ARE THOSE NOT -- REALLY
AVAILABLE ANYMORE.
SO AT DARK CLOTH DIAPERS AND
MOST PEOPLE USE THE MUSEUM
THROUGH SERVICES ARE A COUPLE
PROBLEMS WITH CLOTH DIAPERS FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND EVEN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UPPER AND
MIDDLE CLASS ONE IS THE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES DON'T ACCEPT
CLOTH DIAPERS.
I'M OBVIOUSLY ONCE SOIL THERE US.
RIGHT TO TELL YOU AS A TAX RATE
THEY ARE TOXIC WASTE AND SO --
CHILD CARE FACILITIES DON'T
ACCEPT THEM AS A USABLE FORM THE
OTHER THING THAT PEOPLE DON'T
THINK ABOUT A LOT -- I HAVE
COMMUNITY THAT RELIES HEAVILY ON
LAUNDROMATS IN LAUNDROMATS
ACTUALLY YOU CANNOT USE CLOTH
DIAPERS YOU CAN'T WATCH THEM IN
LAUNDROMATS AND NOW THAT WE'VE
GONE TO LOW FLOW TOILETS WHAT
USED TO HAPPEN I MEAN I'M SORRY
GET SO IN DEPTH BUT LIKE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THIS.
IS I TORN SO WHAT USED TO HAPPEN
LIKE WHEN MY MY MOTHER USED TO
AYE.
DIAPERS AND SHE SAID SHE'D FIRST
WATCHED AMOUNT THE TOILET AND GO
OUTSIDE AND WE AND I WATCHED HIM
I GOT A LOT ABOUT MUCH THEM --
SO BECAUSE WE'VE WE SWITCH TO
LOW FOR TOILETS THAT'S NOT EVEN
A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY TO CLEAN
DIAPERS ALLEN HAS A PRE WASH.
AND SO IT IT REALLY LEAVES -- OF
MOST COMMUNITIES WHO CAN'T
AFFORD AN ACTUAL DIAPER SERVICE
FROM BEING ABLE TO USE OUR RELY
ON CLOTH DIAPERS ALL OKAY.
GREAT AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS -- IT'S IN
THE ANALYSIS SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
POOR WOMAN WHO HAD A CHILD WHO
KEPT THE SAME DIAPER FOR DAYS AT
A TIME.
NEEDS A LOT MORE THAN A 10%
DISCOUNT.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T NEED
THAT DISCOUNT IT ALL.
UP YOU'VE MENTIONED THE CREDIT
ON NOW CAO WORKS.
WOULD IT MAKE MORE SENSE TO
SPEND THIS MONEY TARGETED SAY
THROUGH EITHER MEDI CAL OR CAO
FRESH OR SOME OTHER -- PROGRAM --
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
THAT SO YOU PROBABLY HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR ME I DO KNOW FIRST OF
ALL CAL FRESH WE CAN'T USE -- WE
CAN'T USE FOOD STAMPS
UNFORTUNATELY TO BUY DIAPERS ARE
WAY UP WE'VE GONE THROUGH ALL OF
THESE.
THESE POSSIBILITIES EVEN THROUGH --
CAL WORKS IT'S A DIFFICULT
SITUATION BECAUSE NUMBER ONE THE
MOUNT OF TIME THAT SOMEBODY'S ON
CAL WORKS.
DESPITE HOW LONG THAT THEY NEED
TO BE IN THAT CHILD NEEDS TO BE
IN DIAPERS ALSO THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS SO.
CHILDREN -- BEING BORN INTO
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA A LARGE
NUMBER OF THEM ARE NOT -- ON CAL
WORKS THERE IS AT A DISPARITY
BETWEEN THAT IN SOMETHING LIKE
DIAPER NEED THAT IS SO COSTLY SO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED
TO TWO HOW A HUNDRED DOLLARS
MINIMUM A YEAR PER FAMILY.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS IN
CAN BENEFIT FAR MORE THAN JUST --
POOR WORKING CLASS AND LOWER
MIDDLE CLASS I MEAN THAT'S
GETTING INTO THE RANGE THAT
REALLY DOES ALLEVIATE STRESS OFF
OF MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES.
AND SO WHATWE FIND IS THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AND I I
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH -- DIAPER
BANKS AND AND CAL WORKS
PROPOSALS AND OTHER WAYS TO GET
DIAPERS IN THE HANDS OF POOR
POOR MOMS.
IMPORT MANLEY'S -- BUT IN
PARTICULAR MOMS BUT IN REALITY
WE'RE NOT THE TO REACH THE NEED
THAT WE NEED -- TO ULTIMATELY WE
WE WE SHOULD ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE COSTA DIAPERS -- I'M NOT
QUITE THERE YET I PROMISE YOU
ALL GET THERE -- BUT THIS IS ONE
ONE EASY THING WE CAN DO I WAS
TRYING MY HARDEST TO FIND THE
NUMBER OF KIDS WHO ARE BORN TO
WEALTHY FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA I
CAN'T SEEM TO FIND THAT NUMBER.
BUT WHAT WE DO NOW IS THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN WHO ARE BORN ON MEDI
CAL IS WAY OVER 50% THAT THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN BORN INTO
POVERTY ESPECIALLY BLACK AND
BROWN CHILDREN.
IT IS CLOSER TO TWO THIRDS IN SO
IF YOU ADD THAT ON TOP OF MIDDLE
CLASS YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA GET --
REALLY.
AFFECTING FAMILIES WHO ARE THEIR
MOST CRITICAL TIME HER USING THE
MOST VULNERABLE TIME OF THEIR
COSTS ARE THE HIGHEST IN THESE
NEEDS ARE THE GREATEST AND BY
THE WAY THIS IS.
A NEED THAT CAMP -- BE FOR
FILLED IN ANY OTHER WAY SO I AYE
IF THERE WAS A WAY TO EXEMPT
RICH PEOPLE I MEAN SURE I'D DO
IT -- BUT I I CAN'T SEE A
FUNCTIONAL WAY TO GET THIS TYPE
OF RELIEF AND THE AMOUNT OF
FAMILIES HANDS THAT WE NEEDED TO
GET INTO WITHOUT DEALING WITH IT
AGAIN AT ANOTHER WAY EXCEPT
THROUGH.
THE THE REGRESSIVE NATURE OF
SALES TAX OKAY -- IS THERE ANY
WAY TO DO THROUGH MEDI CAL.
MEDI CAL SO.
YOU WERE ELIGIBLE MIGHT ALSO GET
A VOUCHER FOR A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF DIAPERS WE WE WENT THAT ROUTE.
ORIGINALLY THIS WAS. FIVE YEARS
AGO WAS TALKED OUT OF IT BY THE
BY NOW SENATOR PAN AND I'M I'M
SORRY I CAN'T COME UP WITH A
SPECIFIC REASON OKAY -- BUT IT
IT THERE WAS A REASON BY WHICH
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE USE MEDI CAL
WOULD PUT IN JEOPARDY I THINK
OUR NATIONAL FUNDING.
AND SOME OTHER IN HE IS A
PEDIATRICIAN WHO SPECIALIZES IN
COMMENTS SO -- HE WAS LIKE THE
PERFECT PERSON FOR ME TO ABOUT
MY INITIALTHOUGHTS TO BOUNCE
OFF OF BUT HE DEFINITELY TALKED
ME OUT OF THE MEDI CAL ROUTE AND
I'M SORRY CAM I'LL GET YOU THE
SPECIFICS ON WHY THERE WAS A A
SPECIFIC REASON HE THOUGHT THAT
THAT WOULD WORK.
THANKS IT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT UP FOR A SEVEN MEMBER.
TO REALLY BE A HAPPY TO CO
AUTHOR YOUR BILL.
LOW QUICK QUESTION THOUGH IS
WOULD YOU CONSIDER -- EXAM TO
THE DIAPERS FULL ADULT.
THANK YOU -- IS VOTE BOOK OLDER
OLDER YEAH.
I DID CALL DAY OR PROBABLY ALSO
IN THE DIRE NEED FOR GUESTS OF
DIAPERS SERVICES SO IF YOU DON'T
I'LL CARRY A BILL NEXT YEAR --
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO CO AUTHOR
THIS WITH YOU THE REASON I HAVE
NOT TAKEN ON THE ADULT DIAPER
ISSUE IS ACTUALLY THROUGH.
MEDICARE ADULT DIAPERS YOU CAN
GET A PRESCRIPTION FOR ADULT
DIAPERS AND THEN THEY ARE TAX
FREE.
AND SO THERE IS A MECHANISM
CURRENTLY BY WHICH ADULTS WHO
ARE IN CON IT CAN GET TAX FREE
DIAPERS WHICH IS KIND OF IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT --
IT SHOWS THE DISPARITY IN THE
WAY WE ADDRESS THAT THERE IS NO
WAY TO DO IT OF COURSE THROUGH
THE YOUNGER CHILD BUT AS AS YOU
AGE.
THERE IS A PRESCRIPTION.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD THOUGH THAT
THOSE DIAPERS AREN'T AS NICE AS
THE ONES YOU BUY OVER THE
COUNTER AND SO WE MAY STILL WANT
TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- SO YOU AYE I'VE
TALKED TO YOUR STAFF A LOTABOUT
THIS AND WE SPENT SOME TIME WITH
CD TFA AND FIRST THANK YOU BOTH
FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO WITH THE
DIAPER BANK AND WITH YOUR
SERVICES.
CLEARLY TO MY COMMUNITY -- AND
WE DID TALK TO CD TO A FAN WE
TRIED TO FIND A WAY TO MEANS
TEST THIS AND THEY DID THINK
THEY HAD AN IDEA THE PROBLEM IS
THEY COULDN'T AUDIT THE
BUSINESSES.
AND AT ONE POINT I WAS LIKE WHO
CARES BUT I KNOW HOW HARD YOU
WORK ON THIS AND THERE'S A LARGE
NUMBER OF THE MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE WRITTEN A
LETTER TO BUDGET TO SUPPORT SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS.
YOU HAVE DONE AN INCREASING YOUR
CAL WORKS BILL FROM THIRTY TO
FIFTY DOLLARS AND TO INCREASE
AND TO DO ANOTHER BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO DIAPER BANKS.
AND PART OF THE REASON I
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO THAT IS
BECAUSE I STRUGGLE WITH THIS A
LITTLE BIT EVEN AS A MOM WHO
JUST WHO HAS A VERY YOUNG CHILD --
I WORRYING BECAUSE THEY DO WORK
AT I AM SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
WORKING ON POVERTY AND THE WAY
THAT THIS -- COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT THINGS THIS YEAR AS
WE LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT
ANYTHING THAT TAKES MONEY OUT OF
THE GENERAL FUND.
AND SO FOR ME THE STRUGGLE WAS
DO WE ALLOW WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO
BUY DESIGNER ORGANIC HONEST
DIAPERS -- A SALES TAX EXEMPTION
DOES THAT TAKE IS THAT FAIR TO
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THAT MONEY OUT OF THEIR
PROGRAMS THEIR OTHER PRODUCTS
ALSO PROGRAMS.
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE WORKED VERY
VERY HARD ON THIS.
I KNOW THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO YOU.
AND SO I HAVE ASKED YOU TO TAKE
SOME AMENDMENTS TO HAVE THIS
REVIEWED BY THE LA -- TO SEE IF
THIS IS REALLY THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL THING THAT WE CAN DO
FOR FAMILIES -- BUT I HAVE EVERY
I'VE ALWAYS TOLD YOU THAT I HAVE
EVERY INTENTION OF SUPPORTING
YOU WITH THIS I'VE TOLD YOU THAT
IN EVERY ITERATION THAT THIS IS
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE WHETHER
IT WAS A TRYING TO GET THE MONEY
THROUGH AN ALCOHOL TAX OR
WHATEVER I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT.
I HAD EVERY INTENTION OF
SUPPORTING YOU WITH THIS HOWEVER
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING THAT WE'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT THERE
ISN'T ANOTHER DELIVERY MECHANISM
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ARE TRULY GETTING DOING
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS I KNOW YOU
WANT TO DO AND THAT IS THE ONLY
GOAL THAT I HAVE OF THIS BILL.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE I WOULD JUST -- YOU
KNOW AND I I A THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US AND I AM HAPPY
TO TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS -- ONE
NOT HAPPY EVEN TAKE THEM.
THAT'S HOW AMENDMENTS GO IN THIS
BUILDING RIGHT -- SO.
I WOULD JUST SAY THIS YEAH I I
UNDERSTAND AND WE HAVE LOOKED AT
THIS TEN WAYS -- TO TRY TO GET
TO THE A MEANS TEST I'M IT'S
JUST NOT HOW SALES TAX WORKS
QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW UNLESS.
WE WANT TO EXEMPTS ORGANIC
EXPENSIVE DIAPERS THAT YOU NOW
ARE OUT OF MAYBE A CERTAIN RANGE --
I THINK WE COULD DO THAT BUT IS
I I THINK THAT WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC IN OTHER WAYS -- THE
FACT IS THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S
ANOTHER DISCUSSION GOING ON AND
ONE THAT I FULLY SUPPORT ABOUT
TAMPON TAX.
AND WE'VE MOVED OUT FOR TIME AND
TIME AGAIN SAYING YOU KNOW THIS
IS UNFAIR TO WOMEN IT IS -- IT'S
A SMALL AMOUNT -- THAT IS MORE
BASED ON EQUITY THAN IT IS ON
ACTUAL COST BECAUSE THE COST OF
OF OF COURSE I'M FEMININE
HYGIENE PRODUCTS IS TOO HIGH AS
WELL.
BUT THE THE TAXES IS SMALL BY
COMPARISON OF COURSE WE HAVE
PAID OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
LIFETIME NOT JUST THAT YOURS OUR
CHILDREN ARE YOUNG.
HOWEVER -- THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT A
DISCUSSION ABOUT MEANS TESTING
OR ABOUT POVERTY AND I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
BECAUSE I THINK -- YOU KNOW WHEN
WE LOOK AT TAXES IN THE
REGRESSIVE NATURE OF ALL TAXES
IN THE FAIRNESS AROUND ALL TAXES
QUITE FRANKLY THE DIAPER TAX IS
NOT THAT DIFFERENT IN SOME WAYS
I I WOULD ARGUE THAT THERE IS A
POLICY -- DISCUSSION AROUND WHAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GETTING OUT OF
THE MOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS SAVED
IN A DIAPER TAX I'D BE HAPPY TO
LOOK AT ADDITIONAL TAXES ON THE
WEALTHY THAT HAVE CHILDREN AS A
FORM OF RECOUPING THE COST I'VE
NAY I'M NOT ONE THAT'S THAT
SHIES AWAY FROM.
YOU KNOW THAT TAXING FOLKS TO
PAY FOR FOR WORTHWHILE PROJECTS
THAT THEY COULD THEY ARE REPORT
PROPOSALS SO THEY COULD PAY IN
ANOTHER WAY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
LOOK AT ANY -- ANYTHING THAT
THAT ANY ORGANIZATION COMES UP
WITH AS WAY TO MEANS TEST IT.
WHAT I DON'T WANT THOUGH AND
I'LL BE CLEAR IS I DON'T WANT%
PEOPLE TO HAVE TO SHOW -- THAT
THEY'RE ON WELFARE IN ORDER TO
GET A TAX EXEMPTION YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT IT GOES BEYOND THAT I
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE TO
SHOW -- THAT THEIR POOR I IT YOU
KNOW I I'M A LITTLE SENSITIVE TO
TO THAT ISSUE AS WELL -- AND I
DON'T WANT IT TO BE A SITUATION
THAT DOESN'T ALSO ENCOMPASS --
ARE LOWER MIDDLE CLASS IN OUR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME ISSUE
THAT SO MANY OF OUR OUR POOR
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING IT'S
EXPENSIVE TO HAVE CHILDREN.
IT'S USUALLY YOUNGER FOLKS NOT
ALWAYS BUT YOUNGER FOLKS WERE
THERE STARTED THEIR CAREER WHO
OFTEN ARE YOU ARE SINGLE MOMS
WHO ARE OFTEN TRYING TO PIECE IT
ALL TOGETHER.
AN EXORBITANT NATURE OF THE
DIAPER TAX I WOULD ARGUE IS SO
UNIQUE AND NO OTHER TAX GOING OF
THAT YOU COULD ADDED UP AND
PROVIDE A FULL MONTH'S SUPPLY OF
DIAPERS WHICH WHICH WE KNOW THAT
MONEY IS DEFINITELY GOING
TOWARDS.
IF THERE IS A WAY TO BALANCE
THAT OUT WITH -- WITH ENSURING
THAT THAT WEALTHY PEOPLE DON'T
BENEFIT UNNECESSARILY FROM THIS
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT IT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ENCOMPASS.
THE MOST AMOUNT OF FAMILIES
POSSIBLE THAT REALLY DO DEAL
WITH US AS INITIAL.
I'M TRYING TO DECIDE LET'S SAY
SOME.
YOU KNOW IT'S OKAY IT'S A GOOD
POLICY DISCUSSION YOU BECAUSE I
I READ THE NOW SAYS ON TAMPON
TAX AND I'VE GONE ROUND AND
ROUND WITH MY OWN STUFF AND IT'S
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
WHY -- EXCEPT THAT THERE IS AN
ADDICT IT COSTS MORE BECAUSE THE
SAVINGS IS MORE -- BUT BUT WHY
SOME SALES TAX WE WOULD LOOK AT
AS A MEANS TEST AND OTHERS WE
WOULDN'T WE WE GOT ALL SALES TAX
IT'S MEANS TESTED WHICH I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S RIGHT AND AND
QUITE AND QUITE HONESTLY I
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THAT BUT I
DON'T SEE IT.
IN MY OPINION I DON'T SEE THE
SAME THING THE SET FOR ME THE
TAMPON TAX IN THIS DO AREN'T THE
EXACT SAME THING.
AND I AND WE ASK THE SAME
QUESTIONS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND THE REALITY IS IS TO
ME.
I CAN'T HELP I MEAN I REALLY
HATE GOING I HATE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION AND COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I'M NOT ONE TO TALK
ABOUT -- NO THIS ISN'T ABOUT YOU
THIS IS ABOUT MY OWN PERSONAL
DESIRE NOT TO TALK ABOUT TAMPONS --
BUT I DON'T NECESSARILY I DO
FEEL LIKE IT'S A NECESSITY TO I
I MEAN I HAVE MY BEARD EVERY
MONTH THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO
TO STOP THAT THAT IS A NECESSITY
WHEREAS.
I LOVE HAVING MY CHILD MY CHILD
IS EVERYTHING THERE'S NOT A
PERSON IN THIS ROOM WHO DOESN'T
KNOW HOW MUCH I WORSHIP MY CHILD.
BUT IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT FOR
ME TO HAVE HER IN SO I WONDER I
WORRY SOMETIMES.
IF HOW WE QUALIFY THE WORD
NECESSITY AND I GUESS AND ONCE
YOU HAVE A CHILD YES A DIAPER I
BELIEVE IT IS A NECESSITY.
BUT A STRUGGLE WITH THAT AND
THAT'S AND THAT WAS WHY THERE
WAS A DIFFERENCE IN PART THAT
WAS WHY IN MY ANNOUNCED IN THE
ANNOUNCES IN IN THE CONVERSATION
IT WAS DIFFERENT.
I DID NOT PUSH YOU LIKE I PUSHED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA ASKED
WHAT THE GOALS WERE BECAUSE I'VE
SPENT ENOUGH TIME WITH YOU TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AND I
KNOW WHAT YOUR GOAL IS.
BUT I STILL I DO QUESTION A FOR
GETTING TO THE RIGHT WAY AND I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE WHICH
IS WHY THE AMENDMENTS ARE THE
WAY THEY ARE.
IT'S A WIDE IT IS EXACTLY
THEY'RE DESIGNED NOT TO HURT
THIS BILL BUT THEY'RE DESIGNED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OVER TIME IT
THIS IS NOT THE CORRECT ANSWER
AND WE FIND ANOTHER ANSWER AND
THERE IS A WAY TO MEANS TEST
SEIZE OR ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT WE HAVE THE OPTION TO DO
THAT AND SO.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARGUED WITH THE
GOAL TO SEE YOU SUCCEED BECAUSE
THAT HAS BEEN MY GOAL BUT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THE TOOL
BILLS IS THE SAME BUT I DO SEE
THE GOAL IS ONE YOU BOTH TO
SUCCEED.
AND BELIEVING THAT YOU BOTH HAVE
A POINT ON SOME LEVEL IN YOUR
POLICY AND SO BE IT SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE I'M SURE I'M CLEAR.
THAT THAT THE GOAL HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TO SEE YOU SUCCEED BUT I
DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE ON ALL
OF YOUR REASONING A TIME TO GET
AND THAT'S IT.
AND I I RESPECTFULLY AYE AYE I
THINK THAT IS A GREAT POINT OF
DISCUSSION I IT I A I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ON SOME OF
THIS I MEAN THERE ARE THERE ARE.
I I THINK CHILD BIRTH
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT CAN ALWAYS BE AVOIDED AT
ACT.
IT'S I'M.
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S A NATURAL PART
OF THE HUMAN EXISTENCE IN LIFE
AND SO I DON'TWANT TO DEVALUE --
CHILDBIRTH IS A PART OF OF A A
MANY [inaudible]
PEOPLE'S [inaudible]
NATURAL.
FORM OF LIFE SO I I GUESS WE
WILL JUST.
HAVE TO DISAGREE ON THAT PORTION
OF IT OF COURSE -- BUT A I THINK
WE COULD BOTH AGREE THAT A LOT
OF THINGS THAT ARE TAX FREE
THEY'RE A LOT MORE CHOICE STERN
AND SO [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON A QUICK --
QUESTION HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF GIVING AND SEND
IT TO THE MANUFACTURERS TO BE
ABLE TO DONATE TO ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THIS AND PROVIDED TO THE
PEOPLE FOR FREE.
BUT ACTUALLY IT IS AS IT WAS
STARTED BY HUGGIES THE NATIONAL
DIAPER NETWORK IMPACT WE DO HAVE
A LOT OF INCENTIVES -- TO DONATE
TOWARDS DIAPER BANKS -- AND AND
THE DIAPER COMPANIES ACTUALLY DO
A LOT OF THAT AD THEY NEED TO
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
YEAH I MEAN IT'S JUST STILL AND
AN EVER INCREASING NEED I MEAN I
I OVERALL AND THIS IS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION BUT I THINK
WE SHOULD.
ASK WHY OUR DIAPERS AND FEMININE
HYGIENE PRODUCTS SO EXPENSIVE --
BECAUSE IT IS A NEED AND SOMEHOW --
MANUFACTURES HAVE FOUND A WAY TO
CHARGE A LOT FOR THOSE I THINK
THAT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION WE CAN HAVE BUT THE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE -- AT LEAST
BEEN VERY POSITIVE AND THEY EVEN
ALLOW LIKE FOOD BANKS TO BUY IN
BULK AT DISCOUNTED RATES SO
THAT'S WHEN THE REASONS WE WENT
THE FOOD BANK ROUTE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL KNOW THAT
WE WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO DELIVER
ENOUGH TO THE FOOD BANK'S
THROUGH CAL WORKS ACTUALLY
AFFECT ALL THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN
NEED AND WHO STRUGGLE WITH US
IT'S JUST.
NOT FEASIBLE -- WORKING FAMILIES
ARE GONNA ALL YOU UTILIZE THOSE
RESOURCES AND SOMETIMES CAN'T
BECAUSE OF INCOME QUALIFICATIONS.
I THINK YOU CLOSE BUDGET LIKE
CLOSE AGAIN.
NOW JUST -- I I OBVIOUSLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BUT WHEN
THIS COMES UP THANK YOU.
MOVING FILE ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COME OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
HE'S ALWAYS GREAT.
I LEARNED SO MUCH WHEN I COME TO
YOUR COMMITTEE.
DIAPERS ADULT DIAPERS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS FOR DISABLED
VETERANS.
VETERANS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY HEALTH ISSUES LIKE
CHRONIC PAIN AND POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER FOLLOWING TO
SERVICE CURRENTLY VETERANS LACKS
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO TREAT.
THESE CONDITIONS AND VETERANS
OUT HEAVILY RELY RELY ON OPIATES.
THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT THE
US DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS TREATS CANNABIS AS AN
ILLEGAL SUBSTANCE AND PROHIBITS
VA DOCTORS FROM RECOMMENDING
CANNABIS TO VETERANS.
THE VA ALSO DOES NOT PROVIDE
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS PURCHASED BY
VETERANS FURTHERMORE THE MEDICAL
CANNABIS PROGRAM -- IS CURRENTLY
UNDER UTILIZED BY VETERANS
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM FEAR LOSING
THEIR FEDERAL HEALTH BENEFITS IF
THEY ARE IDENTIFIED AS BEING
CANNABIS USERS ON A GOVERNMENT
LIST.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE WOULD
ALLOW DIS.
VETERANS TO RECEIVED A SALES TAX
EXEMPTION AFFORDED TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS CARD HOLDERS BY
PROVIDING A VETERANS HEALTH
IDENTIFICATION CARD THAT SHOWS
THEIR DISABILITY STATUS AT A
DISPENSARY.
IN DOING SO THIS BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE VETERANS TO BUY FROM
ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AND
CONTINUE. TO LARGER EFFORTS TO
HELP VETERANS GET OFF ADDICTIVE
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY.
CASEY O'CONNOR REPRESENTING
STATE TREASURER BEYOND A MALL.
AND ERIN AUGUSTA'S WITH VETERANS
CANNABIS GROUP MEMBERS ARE
EXPECTED AFTER GUY VOTE.
HI MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER FIONA MOCK PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
AND THE VETERANS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ON THIS WHEN THE
TREASURER WAS AT THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION SHE WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN ILLEGAL CANNABIS
ISSUES AS A COLLECTOR OF THE
TAXES AT THAT TIME.
AND WE CAN BRING CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP TO DISCUSS ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS WE LEARNED
THAT VETERANS WERE NOT REALLY
UTILIZING THE MEDICAL CAMPUS
CAMPUS MARKET WE WANTED TO WORK
ON A WAY TO BRING MORE INTO
THEIR LEGAL REGULATED MARKET.
THEY CAN RELY LESS ON HARMFUL
OPIOIDS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
PRESCRIBED TO OUR VETERANS WE
KNOW THAT TWENTY TWO VETERANS A
DAY ARE COMMITTING SUICIDE.
AND WE KNOW THAT IS 21% HIGHER
THAN OTHER ADULTS IN THE U. S.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY IN THE STATE
NEEDS TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
WE WANTED TO FIND A WAY TO
ENSURE THAT VETERANS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL CARDS COULD
RECEIVE THE SAME BENEFITS OF THE
CARD WHILE ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS WE WERE HEARING FROM
VETERANS.
AND AB FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE IS A
CULMINATION OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
A RECOVERY FIRST STUDY STATES
THAT NOT ONLY ARE VETERANS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND CHRONIC PAIN
PROBLEMS MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
BUT THAT THE COMBINATION OF
OPIOIDS AND SEDATIVES PUTS THE
MEN INCREASED RISK OF ACCIDENTAL
OVERDOSES WE ALSO FOUND THE
STUDY THAT OPIOIDS ARE TIED TO
AN EIGHT TIMES HIGHER RISK OF
DEATH FOR FEMALE VETERANS.
BETWEEN TWENTY TEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN OPIOID ABUSE AND
ADDICTION AMONG VETERANS ROSE
ABOUT 55% WITH ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND VETERANS OR 13% OF THAT
POPULATION ABUSING OPIOIDS.
THE CENTER FOR INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTING UNDER THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT INDICATED THAT
FROM. 220-004-2000 TWELVE SEVEN
POINT 7% OF VA PATIENTS WERE ON
TAKE HOME OPIOIDS BY THE TWENTY
TWELVE TWENTY TWELVE FISCAL YEAR
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN THE AGENCY
CLAIM TO HAVE ISSUED ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION OPIOID
PRESCRIPTIONS. 240-040-3000
VETERANS WHO SHOWED UP AT IT'S A
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MEDICAL
FACILITIES FOR OUTPATIENT CARE --
I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS IF YOU
WOULD LET ME SOME OF THE OUR
RESPONSES TO THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS CONCERNS -- FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WANT ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE OF THE SHRINKING SALES AND
USE TAX MARKET.
VETERANS ARE CURRENTLY NOT
PREVALENT IN THE MEDICAL
CANNABIS FACE ANY ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES THAT BY THIS LANGUAGE
WOULD BE OFFSET BY HAVING A NEW
CONSUMER BASE.
THE ALREADY IS SUPPOSED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THAT MARKET.
SINCE WE'RE HEARING FROM
VETERANS THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE MEDICAL
CARD SPACE WE KNOW CALIFORNIA IS
RECEIVING NO SALES TAX OR THE
RELATED CULTIVATION OR EXCISE
TAX ON THOSE PRODUCTS.
SO BY INCLUDING THEM IN THIS.
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY BRING
IN TWO OUT OF THREE OF THOSE
TAXES AS OPPOSED AS YOU'RE OUT
OF THREE SINCE ARE CURRENTLY NOT
USING THAT MEDICAL CARD --
FURTHERMORE THE US DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS -- AS ANY
ANALYSIS THE WEBSITE STATES THAT
THE VA PARTICIPATION IN STATE
MARIJUANA PROGRAMS DOES NOT
AFFECT ELIGIBILITY FOR THE VA
CARD SERVICES.
MORE OVER THE VA NOTES THAT --
VA PROVIDERS CAN CAN AND DO
DISCUSS MARIJUANA USE WITH
VETERANS AS PART OF
COMPREHENSIVE CARE PLANNING --
CANNABIS IS STILL A SCHEDULE ONE
DRUG AS SUCH THE VA DOCTORS
CANNOT PRESCRIBE MEDICAL
CANNABIS EVEN THOUGH THEY CAN'T
DISCUSS.
OF MARIJUANA AND ITS BENEFITS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE POLICY
BY THE VA IS JUST THAT IT'S A
POLICY IT'S NOT MANDATED.
AND SO THIS COULD BE CHANGE
BASED ON THE WHIMS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING TO
ENSURE OUR STATE'S POLICIES
PROVIDE PROTECTION WHERE WE CAN
FOR THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET IN
OUR STATE GIVE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S VOLATILE GIVEN THE
FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT VOLATILE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE ISSUE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
NINE INSURERS VETERANS ARE NOT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT SHOULD A
CHANGE IN VA POLICY OCCUR AND
ADDRESSES THE VETERANS CONCERNS.
AND THEN I ALSO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ON PENDING.
LEGISLATION AND STATES IN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THERE ALSO IS
A CAR.
A COURT CASE IN NEVADA AS WELL
AS A SUPREME COURT CASE ON THIS
ISSUE SO THAT'S WHY WE FEEL IT
IS APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ACT. TO ENSURE
THAT OUR VETERANS HAVE THE
ACCESS THEY NEED TO THIS AND SO
I JUST WANT TO TURN MY TURN OVER
TO ERIN AUGUSTA'S.
A VETERAN HERE FOR THE VETERANS
CANNABIS GROUP BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ERIN A
JUSTICE OF THE FOUNDER OF THE
VETERANS CANNABIS GROUP IN MARIN
COUNTY.
OUR ADVOCACY GROUP OF VETERANS
USE MEDICINAL CANNABIS -- TO
TREAT THE SYMPTOMS OF COMBAT
RELATED PTSD AND OTHER MEDICAL
ISSUES -- AFTER RETURNING HOME
FROM IRAQ IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
I UNDERSTOOD ME TO THE
TRANSITION FROM MILITARY LIFE TO
CIVILIAN LIFE.
AND I FOUND THAT MEDICAL
CANNABIS HELPED CALM ME DOWN AND
ACTUALLY BRING MY MIND INTO THE
PRESENT -- VETERANS WHO HAVE A
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY
RATING.
I HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE VA TO
GET EVALUATED AND THEN YOU GET
YOUR MEDICAL ID CARD AND IT
STATES IF YOU ARE A SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABLED VETERAN.
SO THERE IS A THIRD PARTY
EVALUATOR THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
THROUGH THIS WHICH IS THE V. --
EIGHT MANY VETERANS RECEIVE VA
VA COMPENSATION FOR THEIR
DISABILITIES ARE ON FIXED INCOME.
AND THE ADDITIONAL COST OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE MEDICAL ID CARD
IS JUST ANOTHER FINANCIAL BURDEN --
THAT MAKES IT HARDER FOR
VETERANS TO ACCESS MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
I ONE THING ABOUT THE VA IS THE
VA DOCTORS WILL NOT BRING IT UP
UNLESS THE VETERAN BRINGS IT UP
THEMSELVES -- SO EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE A A POLICY IT'S IT'S
LIKE YOU SAID IT'S NOT MANDATED --
AND YOU HAVE TO BRING IT UP TO
YOUR POSITION.
FIRST -- SO I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
VETERANS IN MY GROUP.
ARE AFRAID OF LOSING THEIR VA
BENEFITS.
AND THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIALLY NOT BEING ABLE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM IN THE FUTURE
IF ON A GOVERNMENT LISTS SUCH AS
THE STATE MEDICAL ID CARD --
MEDICAL CANNABIS HELPS MANY
VETERANS IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
INCLUDING GET OFF GETTING OFF OF
OPIATES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY TWO
VETERANS COMMITTING SUICIDE
EVERY DAY AND MEDICAL CANNABIS
COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE SOME OF
THEIR LIVES -- THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR LISTENING THAT I RECOGNIZE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE ADDITIONAL IN
THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
JOSH VIRGINIANS LOPING WHEN
INCORPORATED -- PRESENT
ENVELOPING WHEN I AM THE
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE VETERANS
ALLIANCE FOR GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALONG WITH --
G. ACCOUNT EXECUTIVE FOR THE
POINT GROUP.
FULL SUPPORT.
THE MIST MA'AM CHAIR OF MEXICO
US ON BEHALF OF OPERATION EVEN
ACT VETERANS CAMPUS GROUPS
TRAPPERS IN SF THE BAY AREA OUR
EAST BAY IN SACRAMENTO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX OR
AS A STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY HERE
ON BEHALF OF FEES AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MIKE TROUT.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR COOPER
WERE A MEMBER VETERANS CANNABIS
GROUP SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DITION WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS
MEMBERS WISHES.
LENDERS -- THANK YOU SO.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS --
YOU SAID THAT -- RELEASED THE
AUTHOR STATES THAT VETERANS ARE
CONCERNED THAT THEY WILL LOSE
THEIR BENEFITS.
IF IT'S FOUND THAT THEY ARE
USING MARIJUANA IS AT RIGHT NOW
I'M HERE FROM THE VETERANS.
YES [inaudible]
SO WHAT -- WHAT IS CAUSING YOU
TO THINK YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE
YOUR BENEFITS IF YOU USE?
YOUR USED MARIJUANA I ASSUME
RIGHT YEAH SO HAVE YOU LOST YOUR
BUT YOUR VA BENEFITS NOW.
SO THEN WHAT WOULD.
WELL RITA SO IT'S EACH Vì ã
HAS OF AROUND DIRECTORS -- THAT
ARE IN CHARGE OF THE VA HOSPITAL
THERE.
AND THE NOT ALL THE V. A.'S
OPERATE THE SAME EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE A FEDERAL POLICIES OUT
THERE -- BOSS BEING IT BEING IN
CALIFORNIA BEING IN THIS STATE
WE DO HAVE A MEDICAL STATE ID OR
MEDICAL STATE MARIJUANA PROGRAM.
WHICH HELPS WITH THE V. EIGHT
WITH THE VETERANS BECAUSE THERE
IS A POLICY -- TO TO FALL BACK
ON SO IF YOU HAVE YOUR DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION -- FROM AND A
DOCTOR OUTSIDE OF THE VA BECAUSE
OF THE VA DOCTORS WILL NOT ISSUE.
A DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT HELPS YOU --
BUT I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE A LOT OF
VETERANS WHO HAVE.
I PTSD OR OTHER TYPES OF MENTAL
ISSUES WHERE THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING ON A LIST -- THEY
DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW GET THE
STATE ID CARD BECAUSE OF THIS
FEAR.
HER IF I MAY.
YOU HAVEN'T LOST YOUR BENEFITS.
RIGHT I'M ONE PERSON OUT OF THE
TWO MILLION VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA CELLS.
SO.
DO YOU NEED IS THERE A NUMBER
THAT YOU KNOW OF A VETERANS WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR BENEFITS BECAUSE
OF MARIJUANA USE MEDICAL
MARIJUANA USE -- SO WE DON'T
HAVE A NUMBER BUT THE REASON
THAT THERE IS THIS FEAR IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE COURT CASES
PENDING SO IN -- AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL ROMAN VERSE WOULD OCCUR --
ROMAN ASSERTS THAT THE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT GUN CONTROL ACT
VIOLATES THE SECOND AMENDMENT AS
WELL AS HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AGAINST SELF
INCRIMINATION.
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL FIREARM
TRANSACTION FORMS REQUIRE
MEDICAL THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH.
HAVING BE A BENEFIT. FOR YOU
WHAT KIND OF GUN OWNERSHIP RIGHT
BUT THEY'RE SAYING THAT WHEN
THEY FILL OUT THEIR FORMS FOR
THE GUNS IS AS MEDICAL MARIJUANA
USERS TO REPORT ON IT REQUIRES
AND REPORT THE USE OF DRUGS
UNLAWFULLY EVEN WHEN IT IS LEGAL
IN THEIR STATE.
SO THEY'RE WORRIED THAT SINCE
THAT FORM REQUIRES THEM TO EVEN
THOUGH IT'S LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA
THE FORM SAYS IT'S ILLEGAL FOR
THEM TO USE THAT THEY'RE WORRIED
THAT WHEN THEY'RE PULLING UP
THAT FORM THEY'RE COMMITTING
SOME SORT OF PERJURY IN THERE
WHERE THAT'S GOING TO FACTOR
BENEFITS.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A SAFETY
MEASURE IN OUR STATE.
OKAY I'M CONFUSED HOW WOULD THEY
BE COMMITTING PERJURY IF THE
ANSWER THE QUESTION HONESTLY.
BECAUSE THERE IT'S LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA SO THEY THINK IT'S
LEGAL FOR THEM TO USE IT BUT
IT'S SAYING ON THIS FORM.
THAT IT'S UNLAWFUL EVEN WHEN IT
IS LEGAL IN THE STATE AND
THEREFORE AUTOMATICALLY
DISQUALIFIES THEM FROM THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AGAIN I'M
ASKING ABOUT VA BENEFITS I'M NOT
ASKING ABOUT GUN OWNERSHIP.
SO I DO KNOW WHAT I'M ASKING IS
WHO HAS LOST THEIR VA BENEFITS
BECAUSE OF MEDICAL MARIJUANA USE
SO VETERANS THAT ARE IN OPIOID
OR PAIN MEDICATION PROGRAMS.
THOSE THOSE VETERANS IF THEY
HAVE A URINALYSIS THAT HAS --
CANNABIS IN IT THEY ARE
POTENTIALLY AT RISK FOR LOSING
THAT THAT BENEFIT OKAY BUT
VETERANS WHO ARE ON SOME SORT OF
PAIN MANAGEMENT.
THERAPY ARE NOT GIVEN A RANDOM
URINALYSIS TO CHECK TO COULD
VERY ON VERY BEING PRESCRIBED
OPIOID SO THAT DOESN'T EVEN MAKE
ANY SENSE SOME OF THIS A ARE
ACTUALLY.
WHEN THEY TAKE YOUR BLOOD
THEY'LL THEY TEST EVERYTHING --
BUT THEY'RE NOT TESTING YOU FOR
MARIJUANA.
NOW I'M NOT ON THE ROOMS RIGHT.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T DO THAT
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SO.
YOU ARE ASKING.
I'M STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU DON'T YOU DON'T WANT.
VETERANS TO HAVE TO GET THE
STATE ISSUED MEDICAL CANNABIS
CARD.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT IS THIS
BILL RIGHT SKINNER WANT THEM TO
HAVE THE TAX EXEMPTION WANT TO
HAVE TAX EXEMPTION OKAY SO IT IS
A FEAR AMONG VETERANS.
THAT IF THEY GET THE CARD FROM
WHEN I STAND THAT COULD TRIGGER
SOMETHING IS MORE THE FEAR THAT
THIS COULD TRIGGER SOMETHING
THAT WOULD.
OKAY ONE LAST TIME KEEP GOING
BACK TO IS YOU HAVEN'T PRESENTED.
ANYTHING THAT MAKES ANY SENSE AT
SAYS THE FEAR IS LOGICAL BECAUSE
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
NOBODY HAS LOST ANY BENEFITS
NOTHING SO.
BUT THAT'S ALSO BECAUSE LIKE
GOOD SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM BUT WHAT IT'S NOT THE
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK TO THE
VETERANS BECAUSE OF THAT FEAR
THEY'RE NOT ENTERING THE MARKET
SO THEY'RE NOT LOSING THEIR
BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS.
THEY'RE WORRIED IF THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS THEY WILL IN
TURN LOSE THEIR BENEFITS ARE NOT
ENTERING THE LEGAL MARKET SO WE
DON'T HAVE NUMBERS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO IN THIS BILL IS VERY
NARROW. TO JUST SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABILITY VETERANS SO
THE OKAY SO ARE YOU ASKING THEM
TO GET THE CAR I MEAN I'M TRYING
TO GET. TWO OR IT CAN GET THE
CARD.
NOW I MEAN I YOU WANT THEM TO
USE THEIR THEIR VETERAN HELP
IDENTIFICATION CARD.
IN ORDER TO GET THIS TAX
EXEMPTION IS THAT JOIN US IN A
CORRECTLY CORRECT YOU DON'T WANT
THEM TO HAVE TO APPLY FOR THE
STATE ISSUED CART.
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING THEY'RE
AFRAID THAT THAT'S GOING TO
TRIGGER SOMETHING AND THEN
THEY'LL LOSE THEIR VA BENEFITS
SO.
RIGHT CORRECT ME YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THAT WILL AND YOU BELIEVE
THAT THAT WILL NOT HAPPEN AT ALL.
I'M ASKING YOU WHAT THE POINT IS
OF YOUR BILL BECAUSE THEY CAN
GET A STATE ISSUED ID CARD RIGHT
NOW FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS THERE'S
NO NEED.
TO BECAUSE YOU REALIZE YOU'RE
NOT EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE USING
THAT VETERANS HEALTH
IDENTIFICATION CARD FOR ANY
PURPOSES OTHER THAN.
OTHER THAN CHECKING IN AT A VA
FACILITY.
YOU KNOW THAT RIGHT [inaudible]
YES.
SO WE USE.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT IS WHAT THE
CARD IS SO I'M I'M CONFUSED
BECAUSE YOU'RE.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE TRYING.
THIS PUTS THEM IN A WEIRD
PREDICAMENT IF THEY ARE.
THEY'RE USING FIRST OF ALL THAT
THAT FEDERALLY ISSUE CARD THAT
ISN'T SUPPOSED TO BE USED. FOR
PURPOSES OTHER THAN CHECKING
INTO A BE A FACILITY IN GETTING
BE A CARE.
THAT'S A CONCERN BUT ASIDE FROM
THAT I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
THAT THERE'S THIS FEAR THAT.
SO RIGHT NOW FOR ME IS GOING TO
HAVE THIS LIST AND THE FEDS ARE
GOING TO COME IN AND CHECK THE
LIST -- THAT COULD BE SO.
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THEY
CAN ONLY CHECK IN. TO BE A WITH
THE VA CARD. TO GET Vì ã.
IF YOU IN OUR IT'S WHICH IS MOST
WHICH IS.
PRESCRIBING OPIOIDS WE'RE TRYING.
TO PROVIDE A NOTHER OPTION OTHER
THAN OPIOID.
RIGHT IN THE OPTION IS TO GET
THE STATE ISSUED MEDICAL
CANNABIS CARD RIGHT IS NOT
ALREADY AN OPTION THAT IS AN
OPTION BUT WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
NOT USING THE OPTION OR TRYING
TO CREATE AND FACILITATE ANOTHER
WAY TO GET THAT SAME EFFECT.
AND I CAN DEFINITELY LOOK FOR
SOME NUMBERS FOR YOU.
OKAY.
FIND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
SERVICE SOME AN ARMY VETERAN
MYSELF.
I THINK WHAT THIS COMES DOWN TO
IS.
YOU'RE DEALING WITH FEDERAL VA
BENEFITS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STILL CONSIDERS
MARIJUANA ILLEGAL SO NO V. A
DOCTOR IS GOING TO TALK TO OF
THAT ROUND ABOUT MARIJUANA.
SO WE'RE KIND OF IN MIDDLE
GROUND OF FEDERAL LAW A FEDERAL
AGENCY YET.
STATE A CALIFORNIA ALLOWS FOR
MEDICINAL AND RECREATIONAL USE
OF MARIJUANA.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE FIRST
ISSUE WHERE.
I GET ALL THE GETTING PEOPLE OFF
OPIOIDS AND IF SOMEBODY THINKS
MARIJUANA HELPS THEM GREAT.
BUT I DON'T THINK OUR BILL OR
ANY STATE BILL.
IS GOING TO CHANGE THE MIND OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND UNTIL
THEY SAY MARIJUANA IS NOT A
LEGAL THE THE FEDERAL Vì ã
IS NOT GONNA START LETTING --
YOU KNOW DOCTOR STALKER LET.
PATIENTS.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
HONESTLY AND BUT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN STARTING A
CONVERSATION TO SEE [inaudible]
OUR IS IT SOMETHING THAT THE VA
SAYS IF SOMEONE USES MARIJUANA.
DOES THAT SUBJECT THEM TO
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS WITH THE
WHOLE CONTINUUM OF CARE IN THE
VA SYSTEM.
I I I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT YET BUT
DO YOU DO YOU NOW IF IF THAT'S
THE CASE IF.
IF THE VA'S MY PRIMARY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER TO YOU KNOW
I'VE GOT A KNEE REPLACEMENT AND
ON THIS AND I GET TREATED FOR
THAT AND YOU USE MARIJUANA IN A
STATE WHERE IT'S LEGAL DOES THAT
JEOPARDIZE YOUR VETERAN BENEFITS.
IT GETS A CAMPER TENSELY IF YOU
I KNOW VETERANS THAT ARE IN
PROGRAMS WITH THE VA WHERE THEY
HAVE TO SHOW THEIR DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THEIR BENEFITS BECAUSE OF
URINALYSIS FOR BLOOD WORK TESTS
THAT WOULD SHOW OF THE V. EIGHT
TAKE A CALIFORNIA THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM A CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU HAVE TO BE IN A STATE
THAT HAS A OF MEDICAL CARE
PROGRAM AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION
TO BACK THAT UP A VALID.
ONE SO THE THE OF A FEDERAL VA
HOSPITAL OR CLINIC WILL TAKE.
A MEDICAL MARIJUANA OR AYE
MARIJUANA RECOMMENDATION.
THEY'LL TAKE IT IN THE SENSE
THAT YOU'RE FOLLOWING THE STATE
MEDICAL PROGRAM.
AND ARE USING IT FOR MEDICINAL
PURPOSES AND THE FACT THAT YOU
CAN'T -- THE DOCTORS CAN'T TELL
YOU.
IT'S IT'S LIKE DISCLOSING YOU
KNOW YOU'RE MEETING WITH A
DOCTOR YOU WANT TO DISCLOSE ALL
YOUR MEDICATIONS WELL TO GET THE
BEST ADVICE AND TREATMENT SO IN
ORDER TO PROTECT YOURSELF AS A
VETERAN.
YOU NEED TO HAVE A DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND BE IN A STATE
THAT HAS A MEDICAL MARIJUANA
PROGRAM.
SO YES THERE ARE THERE ARE Vì
ã SYSTEMS ARE VA HOSPITALS
OUT THERE THAT -- AND THAT ARE
NOT IN STATES THAT HAVE MEDICAL
PROGRAMS AND THOSE THOSE
VETERANS ARE AT HIGHER RISK OF
LOSING ANY TYPE OF SERVICE OR
PAIN MANAGEMENT -- YOU KNOW --
PROGRAMS.
WHERE DO SO MY OWN RESEARCH I
SERVED IN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION TO FEE A FROM --
200-012-0004 THIS WASN'T AN
ISSUE BACK THEN OBVIOUSLY -- BUT
I'M GONNA DO MY OWN RESEARCH AND
SEE IF IT JEOPARDIZES VETERANS
BENEFITS -- I MEAN I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SIX TAX.
YOU KNOW EXEMPTION HERE BUT IT
KIND OF OPENS UP A BROADER ISSUE --
MEAN YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
REFERRED TO HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT
IT IT IT DOES REACH A LOT OF
THINGS HERE MEAN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT STATE FEDERAL.
HEALTHCARE TAXATION SO -- I KNOW
OUR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT I'M GONNA
DO MY OWN RESEARCH BEFORE YOU
BACK TO VOTE ONLY AND FIND OUT.
RUNNING HIS ANSWER AND FOR IF
YOU DON'T MIND. TO CHAIR OF I
KNOW THIS IS A REAL CONCERN WITH
THE VETERANS AND WHETHER IT'S A
A PERCEIVED REALITY IT'S A
REALITY TO THEM.
AND OBVIOUSLY LOSING.
YOUR MEDICAL BENEFITS AT THE VA --
COULD BE THE LIFE THREATENING
AND SO IT WOULD BE REALLY GREAT
NOT ONLY IF YOU CHECKED IN
BECAUSE I'M NOT A VETERAN OF SEE.
ASSEMBLY WILL MELENDEZ HAS A
BETTER IN THIS GENTLEMAN'S A
VETERAN -- AND I KNOW IF WE WANT
TO DO IT.
YEAH WE WE REALLY WANT TO FIND
OUT THE STATE.
BECAUSE IN THE ORIGINAL BILL WE
DID HAVE THAT YOU HAVE A CARD IN
THERE WE GOT PUSHED BACK FROM
VETERANS THAT WERE.
WERE VERY FEARFUL THAT THEY
WOULD LOSE THEIR BENEFITS AND
PART OF THE CHANGE IS MAKING
SURE.
THAT WE AND JEOPARDIZE THAT.
AND I JUST OUT WANT TO ADD THAT
WHEN WE WERE SPEAKING OF
VETERANS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WE WERE VERY AWARE THAT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE THIS VERY
BROAD ALLOW MORE PEOPLE INTO
THAT MARKET THEN WERE INTENDED.
SO THAT'S WHY WE WENT WITH THE
VETERANS THAT USE THE VA CARD
THIS IS SERVICE CONNECTED
DISABILITY ON THAT CARD BECAUSE
THAT MEANS A V. A DOCTOR SAW
THEM.
SAW THAT THERE DISABILITIES WERE
DIRECTLY LINKED TO THEIR SERVICE
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
SOME SORT OF SEVERE DISABILITY
WHERE THEY NEED SOME SORT OF
MEDICATION.
A LOT OF THEM WANT TO RELY ON
MEDICAL MARIJUANA THEY'RE JUST
NERVOUS TO AS WE JUST WANT HELP
FACILITATE PEOPLE THAT THE
MARKET WAS INTENDED TO HELP.
ACTUALLY UTILIZING IN GETTING
THE HELP THEY WANTED YEAH I GET
THAT BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE RAIN THE OTHER HOLE
RIGHT. TO NEW ASIAN FOR GETTING
TO THE VA THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A RICH BACK
THROUGH S. WHEN I VOTE OKAY I
DON'T GO TO THE BONE YARD BUT I
GUESS I'M GOING TO BONIOR
KEEPING.
LIVING FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY
PERCENT EIGHTY SEVEN NINE ONE A
BILL TO INCENTIVIZE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR YOUR
HELPFUL FEEDBACK AND WE'RE GOING
TO WORK ON DRAFTING AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THAT FEEDBACK.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ESTABLISHED
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS TO
INCENTIVIZE INVESTMENT IN
DESIGNATED LOW INCOME CENSUS
TRACKS.
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
THROUGH SPECIAL FUNDS IN THESE
OWN TO BE ALLOWED TO DEFER OR
ELIMINATE FEDERAL TAXES ON
CAPITAL GAINS.
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
ARE APTLY NAMED THEY PRESENT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER THE FEDERAL MEASURE
LACKS GUIDELINES TO ENSURE THAT
SUCH INVESTMENTS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AB SEVEN NINE ONE SIX TO GIVE
CALIFORNIA VOICE IN THE PROCESS
SO THAT WE CAN HELP TO DETERMINE
THE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS THAT
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED IN
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
THE TAX CREDITS IN THIS BILL
WILL INCENTIVIZE INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A PRESSING
NEED IN OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE'S ALREADY EVIDENCE OF REAL
ESTATE SALES INCREASING PRICES
IN OPPORTUNITIES OWNS STUDIES
HAVE REPEATEDLY DEMONSTRATED
THAT WHEN LAND AND RENTAL PRICES
INCREASE AT THE FRONT OF
DISPLACEMENT INCREASES FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
NOT STAND BY WHILE FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS GENERATE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
INVESTMENTS IN OUR LOWEST INCOME
CENSUS TRACKS WITH NO REQUIRED
PROTECTIONS OR PUBLIC BENEFITS.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE TWO
CREDITS FIRST A TAX CREDIT FOR
QUALIFIED DEVELOPERS TO ACQUIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPERTY IN
ORDER TO KEEP IT AT AFFORDABLE
PRICES.
THE SECOND CREDIT IS MODELED
AFTER THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT A PROVEN AND BIPARTISAN
TAX CREDIT.
THAT WOULD SEEK TO INCENTIVIZE
DEVELOPMENT OF LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
JONES IN ORDER TO SPUR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING IN THE
AREAS OF OUR STATE THAT NEED IT
MOST.
AB SEVEN NINE ONE WATCHING A
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENTS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AND PRESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES PUBLIC
BENEFIT TO ADDRESS OUR STATE'S
MOST PRESSING NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOMES.
HOUSEHOLDS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION ARM
OUT SCHWARTZ PRESIDENT CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP.
AND CYNTHIA PARKER PRESIDENT CEO
OF BRIDGE HOUSING A LEADING
NONPROFIT DEVELOPER AND MANAGER
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK YOU AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT MY BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR STAYING HERE THIS
ITEM -- WHICH I FEEL IS REALLY
IMPORTANT JUST ONE ADDS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID WE HAVE
HARD DATA NOW COMING IN.
THAT THESE OPPORTUNITIES.
DESIGNATIONS JUST BY THE FACT OF
THEIR BEING DESIGNATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ARE HAD CREATING -- HYPER
SPECULATE IF -- FORCES IN SOME
AS PUBLISHED BLOOM BURKE IN
JANUARY.
DOCUMENTED MORE THAN A 50%
INCREASE IN INVESTMENT ACTIVITY
IN OPPORTUNITIES ZONES.
PRICE COMPARED TO NON OPPORTUNE
SERVES ON AREAS BETWEEN THE TIME
OF THE DESIGNATION.
AND THE END OF THE YEAR.
UC BERKELEY I STUDYING ARE THE
GREATER BAY AREA PART OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FOUNDEDOPPORTUNITIES ON
INVESTMENTS ARE ALREADY
CELEBRATING RENTS IN INCREASING
GENTRIFICATION IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
IN THE THIRTEEN COUNTIES
INCLUDING THE NINE BAY AREA
COUNTIES SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
YOLO IN SANTA CRUZ.
SO THE POINT IS THIS IS
HAPPENING NOW.
AND DOING NOTHING IS REALLY NOT
A GREAT OPTION.
CRITICALLY FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
I WANT TO SPEAK JUST BRIEFLY TO
THE FIRST OF THE TWO TAX CREDIT
TOOLS IN THE SEVEN MEMBERS BILL.
THIS IS A CAPITAL GAINS TAX
CREDIT THAT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
HELP.
NONPROFIT CONTROLLED ENTITIES
COMPETE TO BUY APARTMENT
BUILDINGS IN THESE OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS THAT ARE GETTING SNAPPED UP
RIGHT NOW.
AND WE'RE VALUES GOING THROUGH
THE ROOF BECAUSE OF THIS
SPECULATIVE ACTIVITY ONE EXAMPLE.
IN OAKLAND EAST BAY ASIAN LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION RECENTLY
PURCHASED A HUNDRED EIGHTY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOMES IN FIVE
PROPERTIES.
AND I 95% OF THE EXISTING
RESIDENTS.
WERE LOW AND MODERATE INCOME WHO
LIVING IN THOSE BUILDINGS
ALREADY.
HEADED OPPORTUNITIES ON FUND
INVESTOR PURCHASED THOSE
BUILDINGS INSTEAD OF THIS
NONPROFIT.
THEY REQUIRE A MINIMUM 16%
INTERNAL RATE OF RETURN.
JUST DOING BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
MATH THEY WOULD HAVE HAD TO
INCREASE RENTS IN DOUBLE DIGITS
IN MOST OF THE LOW INCOME PEOPLE
AND MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
THE ONLY WAY THAT EACH PAGE
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
WAS ABLE TO BUY THOSE BUILDINGS.
AND BE COMPETITIVE AND THEY'VE
LOST MANY MORE THAN THEY'VE WON
IS BECAUSE OAKLAND VOTERS HAVE
PASSED THEIR OWN.
BOND TO HELP THEM DO THIS STEP
BOND IS NOW EXHAUSTED IN OTHER
RESOURCE.
SO THAT'S WHY THIS IS SUCH A
CRITICAL UP PROGRAM AND I JUST
WANT YOU KNOW I PARTICIPATE IN
TWO NATIONAL FORUMS.
AND EACH TIME I'VE MENTIONED
THIS BILL TO THEM THERE IS
RAMPANT INTEREST FROM OTHER
STATES WE ARE HEAD AND THINKING
ABOUT THIS BUT OTHER STATES ARE
GONNA FOLLOW VERY QUICKLY.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WILL APPROVE
THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
CYNTHIA PARKER AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF BRIDGE
HOUSING.
BRIDGES A THIRTY FIVE YEAR OLD
ORGANIZATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE VERY ACTIVE
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPER AND OWNER.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL OBVIOUSLY BUT ALSO
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WE HAVE LOST A LOT OF TOOLS
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
VERY GENEROUS AND STEPPING UP
AND PROVIDING OTHER SUBSIDY
SOURCES -- JUST ONE EXAMPLE I
MIGHT MENTION IS THAT WHEN THE
THIS BILL THIS -- OPPORTUNITIES
OWN LEGISLATION WAS INCLUDE
INCORPORATED INTO THE TAX CODE
IT ALSO THE TAX CODE ALSO
PROVIDED -- CHANGES TO THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE WHICH
EFFECTIVELY LOWERED THE PRICE
SCENE OF THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
BY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
20%.
BECAUSE WE'RE SO ACTIVELY TRY TO
USE ALL THE TOOLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN OUR TOOLBOX --
BRIDGE VERY QUICKLY STARTED
LOOKING AT OZONE LEGISLATION AND
ALSO WHAT IT MIGHT MEAN TO US
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT BY DOING
THE KIND OF FINANCIAL MODELING
THAT WE HAVE -- AROUND THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WE THINK THAT
IT MIGHT BE ABLE TO BRING THIS
BACK UP TO EVEN -- WENT BEFORE
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE STRUCTURE
WAS WAS BROUGHT DOWN SO SO
QUICKLY -- I ALSO THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT IS MATT IS
MENTIONED IN A AND THE AUTHORS
MENTIONED THAT -- THE
GENTRIFICATION THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS AS A
RESULT -- Z. A WILL HAPPEN
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THIS HAPPENED THIS OCCURS -- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE TO INVESTORS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND THEY COME IN AND
TRY TO INVEST IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WANT TO KEEP
AFFORDABILITY IN PLACE.
BRIDGE HAS MADE A COMMITMENT
WITHIN OUR OWN STRATEGIC PLAN
THAT WE JUST PUBLISH. TO CREATE
NINE THOUSAND NEW UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS IT'S A VERY AMBITIOUS
GOAL THAT WE HAVE.
A BETTER SO WE'RE VERY ACTIVE IN
THE MARKET PLACE THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF MARKETING
BROCHURES THAT ARE GOING ON I
HAVE SEVERAL OF THEM -- AROUND --
Z. -- PARCELS FOR SALE AND AS
MANNERS MENTIONED -- LANCE LANCE
LANCE SALES IN THE SEE AREAS
CALIFORNIA HAS EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE OC.
A CENSUS AREAS -- HAVE SPIKE
TREMENDOUSLY SINCE STATUS FOR
STARTED -- HAPPENING.
WE DON'T HAVE -- VERY HARD DATA
ON HOW THIS IS INCREASED PRICING
ONLY ANECDOTAL AT THE PRESENT
TIME BUT I CAN TELL YOU FROM --
MY OWN -- BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
GUYS TO GO OUT AND LOOK FOR LAND
OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR BRIDGE TO
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A LAST YEAR
WE SAW -- AND PRICE ON A
PROPERTY BEFORE -- Z. WENT INTO
EFFECT AND IT WAS AROUND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR FOR LAND --
THIS YEAR THE SAME MARKETING
BROCHURE WAS LOOKING AT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
A DOOR FOR LAND CLASS SO SAME
PROPERTY -- Z. NOT NO OC SO JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN AND IDEA.
I'M I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO --
THAT WE HAVE -- SEEN OUR
INVESTORS LOOK AT Z..
AND FOR A NON AFFORDABLE
INTERNAL RATE OF RETURN THEY'RE
LOOKING AT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
SIXTEEN AND 18%.
I ARE. FOR AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENTS.
YOU'RE LUCKY IF YOU HAD A 5%
HIGHER ARE.
SO INCENTIVES LIKE THIS WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO BRING AND SOCIALLY
MODIFIED MAJOR THEY DID
INVESTORS OKAY THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN SUPPORT --
PHILLY AS NAME INFLATION. TWENTY
BE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
PROPOSITION US ASSOCIATION HERE
TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
WEARING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU WHEN IS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THAT QUIRK --
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE JUST SAID IS.
AND READING ALSO THE COMMENTARY
OF THE STAFF IS.
OPPORTUNITY JONES ARE BAD FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I CAN'T THIS SEE IT ANY OTHER
WAY -- WE DID HAVE THE
EQUIVALENT IN THE STATE PROGRAM.
WHICH ENDED UP TRANSFERRING HIGH
PAID UNION JOBS.
TO AREAS OF THAT IT MERELY
NEEDED JOBS BUT THEN SENDING
THEM TO MINIMUM WAGE -- THE
OPPORTUNITIES JONES IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT'S DOING TO THE COST OF
HOUSING ALREADY.
IS CRAZY -- I THINK WOULD BE
BETTER OFF WITHOUT THE PROGRAM.
MAYBE I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
BUT THERE ANYWAY WE CAN OPT OUT
IF IT IS A STATE.
SO AM I I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
YOU IF IT'S IT'S IT'S A IT'S AN
ACTUAL QUESTION AND YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS AMONG A LOT OF FOLKS
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY ZONES --
CONVERSELY THERE A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT SEE THEM AS A AS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY SO FOLKS WHO SEE A
POTENTIAL CHALLENGE HERE AND
ALSO.
REAL OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING
INVESTMENT PRIVATE INVESTMENT
CAPITAL INTO CENSUS TRACKS
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY COULD NEED TO INVEST THE
CAPITAL.
THE BIGGER QUESTION FOR US IS
SHOULD CALIFORNIA HAVE A VOICE
IN DIRECTING HOW THAT CAPITAL
WAS ALLOCATED AND WHAT THIS TAX
CREDIT IS SAYING IS THAT YOU MAY
LIKE OPPORTUNITY ZONES YOU MAY
HATE THE IDEA.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
EXPRESS SOME PRIORITIES WITH
INVESTED.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID THAT A PART OF
FINANCES SAID THAT YOU KNOW IN
SEEKING TO DO TAX CONFORMITY AND
THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED THE
DETAILS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD PRIOR TO PRIORITIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE CENSUS
TRACKS SO I THINK THE QUESTION
FOR THE COMMITTEE HERE TODAY IS
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES OWNS THAT
WAS A FACT THAT WAS A PIECE OF
FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
THAT IN FACT THE CENSUS TRACKS
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED ALL EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE OF ON THE
QUESTION IS SHOULD CALIFORNIA
HAVE A VOICE IN THE PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE SOME
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND I THINK THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS YES.
WELL MY PROBLEM IS THAT IT
SOUNDS IS HALF.
JUST THE COST OF THE LAND IS
ENOUGH TO NULLIFY.
I MEAN IT IT'S BETTER OFF
WITHOUT YEAR TAX CREDIT BUT THE
COST OF THE LAND MAY BE IT MAY
EVEN.
NULLIFY THE IMPACT OF YOUR TAX
CREDIT TO THE POINT WHERE IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT EVEN WITH
YOUR TAX CREDIT TO BELT.
I THINK WHAT I AND AND FEEL FREE
TO DROP I THINK WHAT I HEARD IS
THAT IS THAT THERE IS ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT ARE REASONS TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS I DON'T KNOW THAT ANYONE
HAS THE HARD DATA YET TO SAY.
THAT THESE YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
BOARD ARE GOING TO BE TERRIBLE
AND LEAD -- TO YOU KNOW EXTREME
RESULTS BUT I THINK GIVEN WHAT
WE KNOW IN A TOTALLY.
AND ALSO GIVEN WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND ABOUT HOW THIS MARKET
FUNCTIONS GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT OUR STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS.
OUR BEST OPTION AT THIS POINT IS
TO WEIGH IN AND TO DO SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO LEAD TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ALSO PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT IT JUST TO BE CLEAR.
THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF THIS BILL
RIGHT ONE OF THEM IS A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CREDIT THAT'S
FOCUSED ON PREVENTING
DISPLACEMENT THE OTHER IS A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CREDIT
THAT IS FOCUSED ON THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. TO BRING A NEW UNITS ON
MARKET WHAT THAT'S GONNA DO AS
LEVERAGE WHAT WE EXPECTED TO BE
A SIGNIFICANT.
AND FUSION OF CAPITAL INTO THESE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS RATHER THAN
TO BE A SHOPPING MALL OR A HIGH
END RESTAURANT IT WILL FOCUS
THOSE DOLLARS INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN NO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH I I I THINK THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE AGAIN JUST TO SORT OF
ECHO WHAT I SAID BEFORE -- YOU
KNOW THE THE THE AND AND TO STEP
BACK A MOMENT FROM SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION HERE THE THE BIGGER
QUESTION I THINK FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO ANSWER TODAY AND I
THINK THE GOVERNOR SOARED
ANSWERED AS IT SHOULD CALIFORNIA
HAVE A VOICE.
IN DIRECTING THIS.
SPENDING AROUND OPPORTUNITY SO
IT'S SHOULD WE MAKE SURE THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IS GOING TO HAVE
A PUBLIC BENEFIT THAT IT'S GOING
TO BENEFIT THESE COMMUNITIES AND
I THINK THE ANSWER THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY AND SO.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE ARE
SOME WONDERFUL THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP IN A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS CERTAINLY AS AN
ATTORNEY I APPRECIATE QUESTIONS
OF MAKING SURE THAT --
INTERPRETING THE BILL IS IT'S AN
COULD INTERPRET CONSISTED WITH
OUR TENT WERE VERY EAGER TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT SHOULD
CONTINUE.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE THE
GOVERNOR'S INDICATION AS WELL
WE'VE HAD THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IT'S FOR TESTIMONY
ONLY TODAY BUT WE WILL CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I'M NEXT.
OUR FINAL BILLS FILE ITEM TO BY
THE CHAIR.
AB
.
TWENTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS TO AND MISTER CHAIR AB
TWENTY FOUR SEEKS TO DISRUPT.
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY BY
PROVIDING A TARGETED CHILD TAX
CREDIT.
AB TWENTY FOUR REFLECTS A
PRIORITY RECOMMENDATION OF THE
LIFTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY TASK FORCE
PRESENTATION PRESENTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR IN
NOVEMBER.
THIS TAX CREDIT TARGETS DEEP
POVERTY THOSE SURVIVING ON LESS
THAN HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
POVERTY MEASURE A MEASURE THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR COST OF LIVING
DIFFERENCES IN EACH COUNTY.
ENDING CHILDHOOD POVERTY HAS HAS
LONG TERM STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS AND THIS CREDIT HAS
BEEN CAREFULLY DESIGNED.
FIRST THIS CREDIT CONSIDERS A
FAMILY'S TOTAL RESOURCE OF BOTH
PUBLIC PUBLIC PROVIDED SUCH AS
IN KIND BENEFITS AND PRIVATE
SOURCES SUCH AS INCOME FROM MARK.
AND AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES I WILL ADD CHILD CARE
SUBSIDIES TO THIS LIST OF
RESOURCES.
SECOND BEFORE ACCESSING THIS
CREDIT FAMILIES MUST HAVE
APPLIED FOR ALL OVER OTHER
AVAILABLE BENEFITS FINALLY THIS
CREDIT IS BASED ON VERIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
WITH THE TARGETED CHILD TAX
CREDIT WE TAKE AN IMPORTANT STEP
AND FILLING THE COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN TO END CHILD POVERTY THE
TASK FORCE HAS SO DILIGENTLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY LAID OUT.
I HAVE HERE WITH ME TODAY I
CALMLY COLLINS CO CHAIR OF THE
LIFTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY TASK FORCE HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS TO THIS ISSUE OF MADAM
CHAIR AND TO THE TO THE MEMBERS --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
CHILD POVERTY TASK FORCE WILL
COMPREHENSIVE IN ORDER TO BOTH.
AND DEEP CHILD POVERTY AND
REDUCE SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE
OVERALL CHILD POVERTY IN THE
STATE THAT IS ACTUALLY NEVER
HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA B. B..
IT BUT DESPITE THE EFFORTS WHICH
HAVE BEEN MONUMENTAL.
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATIONS -- TO MAINTAIN
THE SAFETY NET IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S BEEN A LACK OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO ACTUALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA TWO MILLION AND SHALL
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LARGEST NUMBER HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF CHILDREN 20% OF
ANY STATE IN THE UNITED STATES.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
OF THOSE CHILDREN.
ARE IN DEEP POVERTY.
AND IT'S THAT POPULATION THAT
THIS TAX CRATERS DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS.
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR FOREIGN
FIFTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IF IN
ONE PLACE THAT WOULD BE LARGER
MORE PEOPLE THAN FOR EXAMPLE THE
CITY OF OAKLAND. SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND OF THOSE CHILDREN.
ARE IN THE DISTRICTS REPRESENTED
BY MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
SIXTY ONE THOUSAND THE ONLY WAY
TO ADDRESS THEM AND BEGIN TO
MOVE THEM INTO A SITUATION WHERE
THEY CAN BEGIN AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN BEGIN. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CAL WORKS OF THE I.
T. C. OF THE WORK BASED BENEFITS.
IS TO PROVIDE THIS A DIRECT
BENEFIT.
THIS ADDRESSES THE CHRONIC
INSTABILITY OF THOSE IN DEEP
POVERTY OBJECTIONS.
IN AND OUT OF HOMELESSNESS --
CAR PROBLEMS THAT CAN'T BE FIXED.
THEIR TELEPHONES -- SHUT OFF.
IN IN SECURE -- CHILD CARE IN
OTHER WORDS THIS PROVIDES THE
BASIC INCOME NECESSARY SO THAT
IT SIMPLY STABILIZE THEIR LIVES
SUFFICIENTLY SO THEY CAN BEGIN
TO MOVE OUT OF DEEP POVERTY AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THE ONLY OF THE OTHER.
UP PROGRAMS SO THIS IS NOT IN
PLACE OF THE CAL WORKS ANY I. T.
C. EXPANSIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS APPROVED IN
THIS LEGISLATURE -- HAS
SUPPORTED AND IS CONTINUING.
TO THE THOSE ARE ALL UNNECESSARY
AND WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM -- THE CHILD POVERTY TASK
FORCE THESE THINGS HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER SO THIS IS NOT IN PLACE
OF OF THOSE MEASURES NOR ARE
THEY IN PLACE OF THIS. THIRTY
THREE ONLY 333%.
OF THOSE PEOPLE IN DEEP POVERTY
IN THE STATE.
ARE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE I. T. C. AND ONLY 20% OF
THOSE IN THE POVERTY ARE ABLE TO
TAKE EGGS TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF CAL WORKS.
SO JUST PUT THIS IN CONTEXT THE
AVERAGE -- MOUNT NECESSARY TO
MOVE THE FAMILY AND IS IN DEEP
POVERTY JUST IN THE POVERTY OUT
OF DEEP POVERTY IS ABOUT FORTY
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO THE PROPOSALS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
YEAR ARE REALLY IMPORTANT BUT
THEY ARE -- FOCUSED ON SHALLOW
POVERTY AND NEAR POVERTY NOT.
NOT DEEP POVERTY [inaudible]
SO.
JUST TO PUT THIS IN A IN A
CONTEXT -- BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A A A TENDENCY AND
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS THAT ARE NEW
PROPOSALS AND BY THE WAY THIS
WAS DEVELOPED BY THE BY THE
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
FOR BYE BYE CAL BY THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIAN
BY THE BUDGET CENTER.
AS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
OF ACTUALLY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN IN DEEP POVERTY IN
THE STATE.
AND THERE'S A TENDENCY WITH
PROGRAMS TO SAY WILL YOU KNOW
LET'S STUDY IT FURTHER.
LET'S WAIT ANOTHER YEAR OR TWO
LET'S LET'S -- FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S ANY POSSIBLE WAY TO DO
IT TO LET LET'S FIGURE OUT ALL
THE DETAILS ON THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT IS.
IF THERE'S A BRIDGE FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S NOT EARTHQUAKE SAFE.
WE FIX IT.
AND IN OUR PERSONAL LIVES IF
THERE'S A BIG HOLE IN THE ROOF
OF OUR HOUSE.
AND THE RAIN IS COMING IN AND WE
CAN AFFORD TO FIX IT.
IT'S A PRIORITY.
WE FIX IT.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN DEEP
POVERTY IN AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND OF THEM AND I CAN
GIVE YOU THE NUMBERS FOR EACH OF
THE DAY EACH OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
SIXTY ONE THOUSAND OF THOSE
CHILDREN.
IN DISTRICTS THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE REPRESENT.
THOSE CHILDREN CAN'T WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY.
AS A STATE TO ADDRESS AND
LITERALLY IN DEEP POVERTY IN
FOUR YEARS AND I THINK IF WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO IT.
WE HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO DO IT --
SO I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE WHEN IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A VOTE --
JESSICA BARTOLO A FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WAS THE CHAIR OF THE
SAFETY NETS OF COULD
SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE CHILD POVERTY
SUBCOMMITTEE AND IT WAS OUT OF
THAT SUBCOMMITTEE THIS PROPOSAL
WAS DEVELOPED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST GIVE OUR FLOW
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- I WANT TO JUST
REMIND YOU WHY IT IS THAT -- WE
FEEL IT IS URGENTLY -- THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO END CHILDHOOD
POVERTY NOT JUST THOSE CHILDREN
SIR BY THE COLORS PROGRAM BUT
ALL CHILDREN.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT CHILDREN
WHO LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY AND
DOOR LIFE LONG?
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR TIME IN
DEEP POVERTY THE LONGER THEY
STAY THERE.
THE LONGER THE CONSEQUENCES THE
DEEPER THE CONSEQUENCES.
CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN DEEP
POVERTY ARE MORE LIKELY TO GROW
UP BEING POOR THEMSELVES AND
RELYING ON PUBLIC BENEFIT
PROGRAMS AS A RESULT OF THEIR
STANDI POVERTY.
THEY HAVE SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS IMPACTS.
AND THAT NOT ONLY -- IMPACTS
THOSE CHILDREN BUT ALSO --
CHILDREN WHO ARE POOR BUT GO TO
THE SAME SCHOOLS AS THEY DO --
BECAUSE THERE'S HIGHER NEEDS FOR
THE THE CHILDREN LIVING IN THE
PROPERTY OVER THE LONG TERM IT
REDUCES THE STRENGTH IN THE
CAPACITY OF THE FUTURE WORKFORCE.
WHICH IS OF CONCERN IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PARTY IS SO DANGEROUS TO
CHILDREN BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THEIR FAMILY IS INDEED
POVERTY AS THEY GO WITHOUT THEIR
BASIC NEEDS.
THIS CREATES A LEVEL OF TOXIC
STRESS THE CHANGES THE BRAIN
CHEMISTRY IN THE CHILD'S BRAIN.
AND IT REDUCES THEIR ABILITY
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO COPE.
THAT'S WHAT THE SCIENCE SAYS
THAT IT TAKES AWAY OR MOVES
THEIR CAPACITY AT TO COPE.
THIS IS THE VERY SAME CAPACITY
THEY WILL NEED NOT ONLY TO
SURVIVE AND POVERTY BUT TO EXIT.
A TO ME THAT'S THAT'S THE MOST
COMPELLING REASON THAT WE ARE
FILE ALLOWING CHILDREN TO RESIDE
IN THE POVERTY WE ARE REMOVING
FROM THEN THE VERY THING THEY
WILL NEED.
IN ORDER TO EXIT POVERTY AS
YOUNG ADULTS.
THERE'S ONE RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
A GROWING UP ANTI POVERTY IS
MORE TOXIC TO A CHILD THE NEO
NATAL.
EXPOSURE TO COCAINE.
AND THINK ABOUT ALL THAT WE'VE
DONE IN OUR IN OUR COUNTRY AND
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS -- ACCESS TO KNEEL EIGHT
THE NEONATAL EXPOSURE TO COCAINE
IF WE IF WE SIMPLY UNDERSTAND
THE ITS WORST TO BE IN POVERTY.
AND YOU KNOW HOW URGENT THE SAYS
AND FINALLY GROWING UP IN
POVERTY NOT ONLY IMPAIRS.
THE BODIES AND THE AND REALLY
THE SPIRITS OF THE SOULS OF
CHILDREN EXPERIENCING THIS.
AMEND THE FUTURE CAPACITY BUT
ALSO THE MENTAL HEALTH AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE IN
THEIR FAMILY AND THIS IS BECAUSE
OF BEING A PARENT AND HAVING A
CHILD WHOSE BASIC NEEDS YOU'RE
NOT ABLE. TO TO MEET --
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
MATERNAL DEPRESSION OR PARENTAL
DEPRESSION.
AND THAT AS WE KNOW.
PUTS DISTANCE BETWEEN A CHILD
AND AND A CHECK AND AN INFANT
AND AND THEIR PARENTS.
AND WAYS THAT UNDERMINES
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS THE NUMBERS
OF OF WORDS THAT THE CHILD --
KNOWS HOW MUCH HOW OFTEN THE
CHILD THE SPOKEN.
TO AT AT A LACK OF ACCESS TO
BASIC NEEDS IS THE NUMBER ONE
CAUSE OF MATERNAL DEPRESSION AS
STUDIED AND RECENTLY REPORTED BY
YALE -- RESEARCHERS ON THE TOPIC.
FOR THESE REASONS AND BECAUSE
THIS IS THE FIRST AND ONLY TIME
THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED HOW DO AND
CHILDHOOD THE POVERTY AMONG ALL
CHILDREN ARE JUST CHILDREN SIR
BY CAL WORKS -- WE ARE URGENTLY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
IF WE DON'T DO THIS WE WILL BE
SAYING THAT IT'S OKAY.
IT'S OKAY IN OUR GREAT STATE AND
OUR GREAT ECONOMY THE FIFTH
LARGEST IN THE WORLD IT'S OKAY.
TO HAVE THIS HAPPEN TO CHILDREN.
AND FOR THAT WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
AS WE GO THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO SHOW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I AM CLEAR LIP SHIELDS WITH THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN
AND ALSO REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA.
INTERFAITH COALITION WHICH
CONSISTS OF STATEWIDE JEWISH
MUSLIM AND CHRISTIAN
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
MORAL ISSUE TO END CHILDHOOD
POVERTY THE DEEPEST ACROSS ALL
OF OUR FAITHS.
AND THEREFORE BELIEVE AB TWENTY
FOUR IS A VITAL STEP TOWARD THAT
GOAL.
THE ORGANICALLY WITH THE
NATIONAL DIAPER BAG NETWORK
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO OWNS
PART.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NATIONAL SPORT SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WAS COURT --
COUPLE QUESTIONS WHEN HE'S GONNA
BE CO AUTHOR YES PLEASE ALL
RIGHT.
SO THIS HITS ALL OF THE THE
CONCERNS I USUALLY HAVE ABOUT
BILLS IT'S REFUNDABLE CREDIT
IT'S GOING TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE --
I THINK OUR MAIN PROBLEM IS
GOING TO BE GETTING THE MONEY
INTO THE BUDGET -- WHAT CAN WE
DO TO HELP?
TALK TO YOUR LOCAL GOVERNOR --
OKAY LET'S DO IT THAT HELPS
LETTERS HELP -- AND AND YOU KNOW
THE OBVIOUSLY.
THE SUPPORT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
ON ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
HELPS -- HE'S BEEN AN AVID
SUPPORTER ANYTHING UP UNTIL NOW
BUT OBVIOUSLY ANY EXTRA SUPPORT
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE IT AND
WILLING TO TAKE IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OTHER MEMBERS RUSSIAN US
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS -- YOU HAVE
MY SUPPORT COME UP FOR A VOTE
BUT WHICH I CLOSE -- YEAH I
ACTUALLY NORMALLY I WOULD JUST
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE --
ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE LATENESS
OF THE HOUR BUT I DO HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY TODAY ON A
WORKING ON WORKING ON GETTING
THIS TASK FORCE AND THEN
SPENDING THE TIME EACH MONTH AND
WATCHING THIS TASK FORCE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND.
HOW WE CAN ELIMINATE DEEP TRIAL
POVERTY AND CHILD POVERTY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS CHANGED
ME?
IT IS NOT JUST CHANGE THE WAY I
LIVE OR THE WAY I LEGISLATOR THE
WHERE IS MY DAUGHTER BUT IT'S
CHANGED THE RULES THAT I CREATED
FOR THIS COMMUTING.
IT IS TO ME ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE QUALITY
OF A CHILD'S LIFE IS IS
EVERYTHING THAT WE WOULD EXPECT
FROM THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD.
AND I TAKE THAT INCREDIBLY
SERIOUSLY.
AND THAT IS WHY THIS YEAR IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE ARE LOOKING AT
WHEN WE TAKE MONEY OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND IT MATTERS.
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT IT
REALLY WILL MOVE THE NEEDLE FOR
CHILDREN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW THIS IS
EXPENSIVE AND I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO COST A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT THE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN IN
THE TIME AND ENERGY THAT THIS
COMMITTEE AND THIS TASK FORCE
HAS PUT TOGETHER SHOWS THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST VITAL THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO FOR THE CHILDREN
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT WILL BRING
THAT UP AT A FUTURE COMMITTEE
HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HER PARENTS [inaudible]
WHERE TURNED?
WHEN I?
USED